if you are considering transitioning
careers to become a software developer
watch this course this course is
designed to prevent the common mistakes
and missteps that discourage many
beginners it offers Clarity tools and
strategies to efficiently achieve your
coding goals whether that's securing a
high-paying job launching a tech startup
or just exploring the world of software
development zuen prab was a lawyer and
transitioned to becoming a Google
engineer now he helps others with their
career transitions hi guys welcome my
name is Zubin prap I'm a software
engineer and a devell engineerr
currently chain link Labs before this I
was Google as an engineer and before
that I was a corporate lawyer for over
15 years and I went into executive
management for a while had my own
startup for a while that's kind of how I
learned to code and this little mini
course that I'm releasing for you guys
through free Cod camp now is an updated
version of the original course that I
released 3 years ago um maybe four years
ago actually now where I when I finally
succeeded in my career transition from
lawy I was 38 or 39 at the the time and
I'd become a software engineer and I you
know got the offers that I'd applied for
I was you know top of the world and I'd
promised to Quincy the founder of free
code camp in a podcast with him right
after I completed my career transition
that I was going to make this course
that documented everything that I'd wish
I'd known like three or four years
before cuz I had really struggled for
three or 4 years trying this thing
trying that thing you know I was in my
30s there was a lot of sacrifice and
risk involved a lot of fear and so I
tried all sorts of things to to to make
the transition and I kept failing I
learned all sorts tried to learn all
sorts of tools and languages and I I
didn't realize that there's a big
difference between learning how to code
and actually becoming a professional
software engineer massive difference and
I didn't appreciate that back then so it
cost me hundreds of thousands of dollars
in you know in Lost income and and all
kinds of things and four plus years of
real struggle and self-doubt and you
know Destro damaging my confidence and
having to rebuild it so I promised
Quincy back then um during the podcast
that you know I'm going to do this
course and so I did release it and now
this is the updated vers version this is
the history of the course so this course
is really I call it you know everything
you need to know before you learn to
code because it's not about the actual
coding itself it's about all the things
you need to know to build the right plan
to set the right expectations and to
know how to put yourself through the
process of transitioning from being a
non-technical person to a professional
level software engineer right so it's
how do you build a plan how do you
become the sort of person you need to be
what habits and practices and
expectations do you need to have so
that's really so I call this the you
know before you learn to code everything
you need to know course now couple of
things just to be very clear this is not
really probably well suited for people
who are just students who've never
actually had a career before and the
reason I'm saying that is I finished Law
School in 2003 right so that's 20 years
ago I I've lost touch with what it's
like to be University student these
these days and and approach the job
market from that perspective this is
very much a course for people who are in
busy careers already even if they're in
it but non- technical non-coding sort of
careers or any other career like i' I've
coach people around the world now you
know lawyers therapists you know theater
personalities all sorts of people
security cyber security folks I've
coached them all you know on this
process of career change and becoming a
professional coder so this is for people
who have existing careers who are
looking to switch careers who want to
acquire Advanced like you know
professional level coding skills and
become professional coders whether it's
data science data analysis software
engineering they're not you know you
could argue whether or not they're
coding but I'm trying to include
anything that involves scripting or
software engineering in this right so
this is for that kind of person uh I am
not an expert for for students I'm sorry
but I'm not anymore I'd be lying if I
said I was it's been too long uh I've
lost that perspective right but I am
very much I consider myself to be an
expert in career change because I've
done it myself three careers in four
countries and most recently to software
engineering in my late late 30s you know
even ending up at places like chain link
where I I'm now and software engineering
um you know at at at Google before that
right so this is really important for
you guys to understand before you go now
I had no way of knowing how long the
this entire Journey was going to take me
when I was trying to transition and you
know because I I tried and failed like I
said four times before all the way
through my mid-30s I tried every year I
tried a different thing for several
months and quit and fail and so that's
what I'm I'm trying to achieve here is
to save you four years if I can or more
right and and help you understand what
the process is going to look like so
that's a bit of an introduction about me
this is going to help you understand
what to expect from this course it's not
going to be about Hands-On coding it's
meant for those of you who haven't
started learning to code yet or maybe
you've been trying for 3 or four 5
months finding it frustrating not sure
what to expect what's this cost it's not
that long and see just all the tools and
techniques that I had to develop over
those four years this course really
represents my diary entries for all
those four years all the things I did
wrong I'm sort of re repurposing that
into actionable items that you can use
so that's a bit of introduction and I
hope you get a lot of value out of this
course and if there's anywhere I can
help you reach out on LinkedIn or
Twitter or whatever I'll see you in
another
video
welcome to this course on before you
learn to code all the important things
you need to know to avoid failure and
discouragement on your journey to code
if you're here it means that you're
either interested in starting to learn
to code or you've just started and are a
code newbie either way it's super
exciting and I'm glad you're here I
can't wait to share some of the
learnings that I've had with you and so
let's just get into it now you can get a
sense of this SC from the website
matchfit mastery.com but I'm also going
to take you through a high level
introduction of the course right now so
what is this course I have designed this
course for people like you people who
have either just started or are
seriously thinking of learning to code
and this course teaches you all the
skills that you need to learn to code
but it does not teach you to actually
code that's a separate topic alog
together now most people just Dive Right
into coding right into trying to teach
themselves coding
without first adequately preparing
themselves it's like running a marathon
but with zero training it it just
doesn't work because then when you fail
or you feel overwhelmed by the situation
you just assume that you can't learn to
code and I know this from personal
experience because that is exactly what
I did not once but twice twice I tried
to teach myself to code by just throwing
myself into it without a proper plan and
both times I failed
so what did I do right the third time
around well that's exactly what this
whole course is going to be about so the
first time you go through this though I
do recommend you do it end to end even
though I've designed it as a Hop On Hop
Off experience where you can dip in and
dip out I really recommend that the
first time you go through the entire
thing even if you do it at 1.5 speed
just go through the whole thing because
that'll give you a sense of what to
expect not just from the course but also
from coding generally so who is this
course for then well it's for anyone who
wants to know what it means to learn to
code and how to build an effective
learning plan around that and what to
expect along the way it doesn't matter
whether you've got any coding experience
it doesn't even matter whether you've
seen a line of code not necessary all
that matters is that you're thinking
about it or you've just started or have
tried before and have
failed if you want to ensure that you
save time and effort and money on your
journey then this is really the the
course for you that's why I made it
because when you buy it you get lifelong
access which is fantastic because I will
keep updating it from time to time with
new tips and techniques that will save
you even more time money and
energy now I know I talk about these
three things these three very important
resources being money time and energy
but in my view the most valuable of
these three resources is your time
because money and energy sort of comes
back you can go up and down but time you
just just can't recover it lost time is
lost time and so a lot of the focus on
in this course is really on saving you
time and through that of course you're
going to end up saving effort and very
likely money as well I personally wasted
more than eight months of my life and
over
$1,100 teaching myself to code in very
ineffective ways but 90% of my learning
ended up coming in less than six months
and for less than $200 it's that kind of
learning and optimization that I want to
share with you in this course but it
begs the question who am I and why
should you bother listening to what I'm
saying well a little bit of background
in me I am a lifelong learner I
qualified as a lawyer many many years
ago and I practiced corporate law for
over a decade in three countries I then
changed careers did an MBA went to the
management track along the way I taught
myself product management skills I
taught myself how to play play the
guitar I taught myself how to code and
so I've evolved over that period certain
habits and techniques to learning and
optimizing the learning that anyone has
to go through when they acquire a new
skill and I realized that my entire
process was so inefficient and so slow
and most people still do the same things
it's it's not an efficient process but
this course will give you some efficient
techniques or rather techniques that'll
make it a lot more efficient for you so
so what I did in a year you could
legitimately expect to do in much much
less time and probably much less wasted
effort as you progress through this
short course I hope you're going to want
to ask a lot of questions and clarify
some things I think that's a fantastic
way to learn and consolidate your
learning I encourage you to do that and
I encourage you to use the Q&A for if
available because that way other people
can learn from you and participate in
your Learning Journey if that is
unavailable for whatever reason or you
feel you need to reach out to me in
another format I'm always available on
Twitter as well and sometimes on
LinkedIn though I'm a little less
responsive on LinkedIn for a number of
reasons but Twitter is great feel free
to reach out anytime and I will do my
best to help you so now that we've
covered how to reach me who I am what
this course is about and who is for I'm
getting really excited I'm um I'm really
excited for you and I can't wait to jump
into this journey with you so let's just
Dive Right In in the next section we
going to talk through the goals that I
have for you and for myself in this
course so I'll see you
there okay welcome back to this section
in this section I'm going to take you
through the main course goals that I
have I have two categories of goals that
I wanted to achieve um my personal goals
in making this course and my goals for
you within the category of my personal
goals for this course number one I want
you to feel and know at the end of it
that you've made a good investment in
getting this course number two I want to
save you a lot of time money and effort
and three I want to give you the
self-confidence to pursue your learning
objectives now let's talk about my goals
for
you this course is really about you I
haven't lost sight of that and it's
about giving you the best knowledge and
tools to achieve your learning
objectives so it's about making sure
that at the end of the course you have
the these things one you are equipped to
save a lot of time money and
effort two you are crystal clear on the
following your coding goals your coding
plan or path to achieve these
goals the steps routines habits and
timelines required to achieve your goals
pay careful attention to those specific
choice of words because they're all very
deliberate the fourth goal I have for
you is that I want to ensure that you
can recognize myths or mismatched
expectations that stand in the way of
your learning to
program fifth goal I want you to be able
to use effective tools and strategies
that make your coding Journey enjoyable
positive and as discouragement free as
possible because believe me there's a
lot of discouragement that you will
encounter I want to minimize that goal
six for you is that I want you to be
able to recognize the pitfalls and
diversions that you will inevitably
encounter so that you can make decisions
that help you achieve your goals rather
than delay you or derail you the seventh
goal is that you can proceed with
confidence resilience and Clarity and be
a highly effective lifelong learner and
that's something I'd like to emphasize
here that the skills and the abilities
um that I'll be talking about over the
course of this um program really to
equip you to be a lifelong learner while
it's wrapped around a concept of
learning to program computers almost
everything you learn in this program is
about lifelong learning and the ability
to keep learning as you proceed through
life now I am convinced that you can do
all of these and more everybody can it
is not easy but it's not impossible in
fact it's totally achievable for
everybody so if you've come this far I'm
absolutely 100% convinced that you've
got the willpower you've got the hunger
you've got the drive to do it so don't
stop don't ever
stop okay now that we've established our
course goals let's talk about how you
can get the most out of this course the
suggestions that I'm going to put
forward here are based on largely my
personal experience but also the
experience of all the super Learners
around me that I've read about or met
personally this is something I've
studied and researched extensively and
and it really does boil down to two
things preparation and mindset or you
could call it mentality or something
else but preparation and mindset are the
two basic keys to your learning
objectives so now sharing these with you
is really the first step in helping you
achieve your goals and I know it might
sound a little bit like I'm preaching or
something um and I apologize for that
but this is just so fundamental that
your success uccess in all the sections
from here onwards starts with you
getting good at this preparation and
mindset so to get the most out of this
course I recommend you practice the
following mindsets note now that I'm
always using the word practice in this
course it is a common mistake to think
that you need to have these skills right
off the bat that they come out fully
formed or that they natural and inherent
in people that is a complete complete
myth the difficult skills in life do
require us to overcome our natural
inclinations which is laziness and
inertia anyway I recommend that you
practice these
mindsets over and over until they become
a natural part of your
thinking
one inertia is natural normal and you
must expect it look there going to be
days when you just don't feel like it
and that's okay sometimes you do need a
break especially when you're learning
difficult skills and there's a bit of
mental overload what's known as
cognitive overload but off days or days
that you take off and not do anything
are the exception they cannot be the
norm so you must make sure that your off
days are only the exception that's the
bit that takes effort two you should see
your frustration as a signal that
something needs a bit more work now I
will talk about this a little bit more
as we go through the course but some
things are signals and some things
aren't and frustration is a signal that
whatever you're tackling at that point
in time needs a little bit more work
it's it's not that it's too difficult
for you or that you're not smart enough
that's the wrong message to take out of
frustration now both may feel true in
that moment you may really feel that
you're not smart enough or it's too hard
for you it's insurmountable for you but
with effort both will be proved to be
false or in other words you put in the
effort with the right mindset and you
will show to yourself that you are smart
enough and it wasn't that hard over time
it will yield to you so frustration is
just a signal that something needs a
little bit more work and effort on your
part or that you must just keep going
three try and have a growth mindset and
not a fixed mindset so this means that
you should try to view your skills as a
dynamic thing something that evolves and
grows and develops and improves over
time don't see yourself as fixed or you
will feel stuck and then it will become
true for you that you can't actually
grow the mindset is critical here in
fact these ideas have come from a
phenomenal book by a psychologist called
Carol Dre um the book's called mindset
and it's it's an optional reading I'll
include the um the links in in the in
the notes to this class um or for a
short synopsis you may want to check out
her popular Ted Talk it's in fact a very
highly regarded Ted Talk on exactly this
side subject the growth mindset vers
versus the fixed mindset number four
remind yourself that time and energy
will combine together to help you make
progress now another way to think of
this energy is to think of it as effort
the point is that without putting in
both time and effort SL energy you are
not likely to get to your goal you can
invert this concept if it helps and
think of it as the only thing separating
you from your your goal is time and
effort that's
it number five expect and accept that
your assessment of time and energy will
almost always be wrong now this is
unfortunate but true in fact it's a
well-known phenomenon documented and
called the planning fallacy again I'll
include some um notes and URLs if you
want to look at it it's not essential
but it's just good to know as part of
your preparation that these things are
normal and common and well documented
now this planning fallacy where things
take longer or more time and energy um
than you anticipated it is just part of
the learning and as time goes on you
will get better at at sensing that
that's what's going on but it doesn't
mean you have to like it I totally get
it but do try and accept it it's
possibly a fact of life that we just
need to live with now the more time you
put in the better you get at assessing
how much time things will take so
initially you'll get it wildly wrong and
over time you'll get much better at
estimating you probably don't remember
just how hard it was for you to write to
learn to write the alphabet for example
um but if you watch a Kindergarten kid
you can see how slowly he or she forms
the A and the B and the C and the D it's
really really hard for them sometimes um
they feel it's too hard um when they
can't remember the shape of a given
letter now it's the same principle for
coding or for anything else that you're
acquiring a new skill that you're
requiring at first it's going to be
really slow and frustrating it'll be
cognitively or mentally very hard for
you and that means it will take you
longer than you're secretly hoping so
just be mindful of that develop the
mindset that that's normal it's part of
the growing process don't be discouraged
or too frustrated by that okay you ready
good let's keep going to the next
section okay welcome back in the last
video we talked about the essential
mindsets and mentalities and attitudes
that you need to have in order to get
the most out of this course um as you
probably know learning to code is like
any other project it requires a
framework a lot of planning um
monitoring your own performance your
direction your pace and the outcomes
you're
achieving when you get off track you
need to revisit the goals and bring
yourself back on track but for that you
need to actually have well-laid out
goals now there are tons of Frameworks
that say the same things but with
different kind of words a common
framework that can be used for these
kinds of planned activities especially
personal development projects um which I
favor is called the five W's and one
H the five W's
are Y what where who when and the 1 H is
the how but you know to be honest I
think the how is covered by the what
where who and when it's implicit and
encapsulated in all of them
to me all of that adds up to the
how so in the rest of this section of
the course not this video just the
section of this course we are going to
apply this 5w framework to you
specifically this framework will help
you achieve one of your goals total
Clarity that's the goal that's what this
framework is going to help you get
clarity on your
expectations from yourself from the
process of learning
and your definition of success we need
Clarity on all three so at this stage I
think it's probably a good time for you
to pause a bit and to think very
carefully and I mean this just pause
here and write out your
expectations what do you expect from
yourself over the next 12 months in
terms of your coding Journey what
behaviors and commitments are you
prepared to make to what do you expect
from this process of learning so this
could include a slow but steady rate of
improvement or you would expect
frustration or a sense of accomplishment
Pride
progress next have a think about what
success looks like to you it's very hard
to know we've succeeded if we're not
clear on what it looks like now
visualizing or identifying what a
successful outcome looks like is is a
hard one
and most people don't spend enough time
in being specific but by defining
realistic but big goals and being very
clear on how you would know when you
have achieved them you can keep yourself
very inspired and
motivated so definitely take a moment
and think about those three things but
you know don't worry too much as this is
not a one-time exercise you will need to
keep ref returning to this and refining
it all along your journey as you get
more information as you learn more about
code as you learn about yourself and
your learning style keep coming back so
this is going to be a dynamic and
constant exercise but for now it's a
great idea to do some initial thinking
and expectation setting right away so
stop now and do it okay done that good
now that you've done that hold on to it
sit on it for a bit um over the next few
sections and videos we're going to spend
time on each of those five W's and this
will help you think deeper on each of
your answers
uh refine them and improve them so that
you have total Clarity in your mind
about what it is that you're seeking to
achieve and that Clarity is going to be
your compass through your entire coding
Journey this is really important guys
all right I'll see you in the next video
okay welcome back in the last video we
talked about the five ws and how each of
them is really important and integral um
they essential steps in you putting
together your plan to achieve your
learning goals now in the next few
videos we're going to talk about each of
those five W's and we're going to tackle
each of them one at a time and go into
some amount of detail and let me tell
you this is going to be one of the most
important exercises in self-reflection
you're going to do these five ws are
going to be the things that you come
back to over and over and over again
every time you get discouraged or
sidetracked or you know derail as part
of your Learning Journey um there's
going to be a lot of information that's
confusing and that you're going to feel
very conflicted about and this is the
stuff um the five ws in particular
that's going to really really help you
decide what to do next reorient yourself
towards your goals and just pursue them
so a very very useful framework and
going to be an ongoing part of your
journey so let's get
started okay well the first thing I
suggest we start with is why you want to
learn to code so why are you learning to
code have a good think about this I've
got to admit when I first asked myself
this question it seemed totally obvious
and I took my first response the most
superficial response as the obvious
right answer that was a mistake the
reason it's a mistake is because
sometimes we take the first answer as
the real reason but it's not the first
answer is in fact rarely the root reason
as to why you want to do something
the way to get to the root reason is to
keep asking yourself why so literally
ask yourself why you come up with an
answer ask yourself why that answer now
this is a little more clear with an
example so I'll share with you my
personal example and this is a snapshot
from about one year into my first
attempt to learn to
code when I first started I really
hadn't thought about why or what or made
any plan and that was a huge mistake in
hindsight it cost me a lot of time and
money and energy I just decided instead
that I wanted to write code so here's my
why from back then why to write cool
apps now that seems like an obvious and
very reasonable answer and I dare say a
lot of people have that that thought in
their head but it's insufficient it's
not the whole story and the problem with
this answer is that it does not give you
enough Direction Why
because anything that could help you
write a cool app then becomes part of
your learning plan and that is the wrong
way to go about it it's dangerously
general what sort of apps mobile desktop
web apps hybrid scripts now I learned
this the hard way a year after getting
sidetracked and overwhelmed and doing
too much irrelevant stuff instead it
should have been like this why to write
cool apps why I want to launch my own
product why to pursue my entrepreneurial
dreams why because I believe that this
is what I would most enjoy in my life
now at some point if you ask yourself
why enough times you will get to
something you believe very very strongly
in this is something that is fundamental
to your reason to code this is very very
important because it helps to answer the
next question which is what do you want
to learn to code there are so many
options here so it is very important to
work backwards from your goal and here
is a very important test the answer to
your what must correlate significantly
to your why here's an example for me
what do I want to build a cool app okay
what kind one that I can monetize into a
product okay what kind of product some
sort of web app or software as a service
so what do I need to learn then web
development front end backend security
and penetration texting maybe not so
much of that Which languages help me do
most of this actually does the choice of
language even
matter now this may seem obvious and
easy but I can promise you that if if
you're doing it properly this will not
be an instant exercise in fact it's
going to take effort you may need to
spend an hour or more really thinking
really thinking hard and once you have
your top level learning objective that
is your primary learning goal then you
need to break that down into smaller
chunks for example webd what does that
mean front end back end or is it safe to
ignore tutorials about authentication
and security and database design
Etc let's start with web development
Basics then for the front end perhaps
well that's just HTML CSS and
JavaScript now your goals may be
different maybe you want to get a job as
a mobile developer or a job as a backend
developer in python or something like
that but you need to be crystal clear
about your objective so that every hour
of study and research that you invest is
in a subject
that takes you closer to your goal
directly and by that I mean the shortest
possible route between you and your goal
some subjects may appear to be related
or appealing or relevant um but are they
critical to your goal and you can see
here that when you pursue the goals that
are not quite critical or the learning
objectives that are maybe indirect um
and merely represent nice to haves
rather than the absolute Essentials your
path to success is extremely convoluted
and twisted and messy that's why it's
important to focus only in the musthave
skills the minimum skills required to
attain your goals and not be distracted
by the nice to have skills when learning
a new skill focus is the absolute key
and the less topics you do means the
more progress you're going to make so be
very focused on the minimum requirements
to achieve your goal and separate your
learning tasks into the musthaves and
the nice to haves there is no one right
answer so this takes practice and
refinement over time and like I said
discipline now it's your turn take a
moment step away from the computer or
your phone and write down your wise
followed by your wats and make sure that
they
correlate then come back and put it down
in the exercise that follows this video
and share it with others
welcome back in the last video we
covered the first of the two W's which
is why you want to learn to code and
what you want to code now in this
section we're going to talk about the
third W The Who specifically who are you
going to get support from on your
Learning
Journey as with any Journey you need a
good map and if you're a hia you know
that different Maps can cause confusion
and
frustration the same principle applies
to learning a new skill like
coding finding a person to model is
critical because that is the best map or
Compass to have to choose the best
people you need to have done the
exercises around identifying what you
want to achieve in the previous videos
now just a quick side note and I
apologize but I'm probably going to
repeat this several times but it's
really really important anytime you
adjust one of the W's in your 5w plan
please please make sure that you examine
all the other W's and update them as
necessary all right getting back to
choosing the best
people my suggestion and my experience
has been it's best to choose one or two
people who have done what you would like
to do if they've achieved your goals
that is they've done what you intend to
do then they are the people to model
that's it now very quick update for 2024
because of the rise of the way social
media has started to influence people
and just the amount of content out there
that's being produced by people I think
it's now even more important than ever
before to distinguish between opinions
especially since there's no shortage of
that on the internet and actual advice
and the definition I adopt which I found
to help me a lot uh which I hope will
help you is opinions are what most
people have as a point of view and
usually they may or may not actually
have directly done or U Been uh
experienced in what you're trying to do
however advice by definition to me can
only come from someone who's done
exactly what I'm trying to do who have
direct lived experience of that
everything else is just an opinion and
I've learned especially as more and more
stuff comes out in the internet to just
tune out that it's not so much who I
follow or who I listen to anymore most
of my work is spent tuning things out
right and just finding one or two you
don't need more than that people who
actually done what I'm trying to do um
and who are able to share their
experience and it ideally somebody
really close somebody who I can meet in
person if not somebody I can speak to on
the phone or online and if not interact
with you know via um link or whatever it
is right so those are the layers so I'd
encourage you to really be strict about
the kind of people you take uh
information from because to be honest N9
times out of 10 especially these days a
lot of information is sent out by people
who've never actually done stuff they
may have read a book or you know um
followed some other influence and
they're trying to sort of build
expertise in that area to be honest
without having lived the experience if
you haven't actually gone on to to Rome
you can't really describe what Rome um
is like to someone no matter how many
YouTube videos you watched right so
that's the kind of analogy I'd use there
so think about that very carefully and
try and protect your focus and your mind
space as much as you can by tuning out
excluding rather than let letting too
many points of view come in because
that'll just confuse you a lot that's
the most important and probably the only
really meaningful helpful
rule think of them as mentors or models
I mean pick pick a label that makes you
happy the name doesn't really matter
the important thing is how do you find
these people well in some cases you may
actually know them and you'd be
surprised at how many very very eligible
mentors and models are actually around
you just don't overlook someone only
because they've not yet made it big or
found a job you know there may be 3
months or six months ahead of you on the
journey but that's very valuable too and
then there's always social media I've
found great success with looking up
people on Twitter or you YouTube and
Linkedin and just reaching out and often
online communities are great places to
find people um you can get inspiration
from or get guidance from personally I
found fantastic models from online
communities like the free code Camp
Community some on RIT some slack
channels and so on now it's tempting to
go a bit crazy and spend all your time
on these social media sites and you know
accumulate a bunch of people that you
can go to I suggest you don't do that
that'll actually waste you more time
then it'll save you in my experience the
optimum range is you need one to three
solid reliable trustworthy people and
while many people may not be as
available as you would like they are
usually more available and approachable
than you think even if you reach out C
on on Twitter or even YouTube so just
reach out there's only benefits to be
had you may just find yourself a
fantastic model who's happy to help you
you should set your expectations what
you want from these models just
practical advice
not inspirational advice inspiration is
good but at the end of the day it can
run out whereas practical advice will
make you move forward so I don't
generally think that having models like
billionaire startup Founders is very
helpful it can actually be
counterproductive especially since it's
hard to separate fiction from fact when
it comes to learning from them and their
experience unless you happen to know
them personally and then they can have
an honest conversation with you about
their
experience so let's now talk about in
what moments or what times along your
journey that you're going to need a
mentor or a
model the answer is really anytime
you're confused about what the right
next step is for you do you want to
learn this Frame framework should you
build the skill should you learn um this
particular text stack should you apply
for that kind of job these are the
questions you can take to a good Mentor
a great time to consult your Mentor or
one of your models is when you're
receiving a lot of conflicting and
confusing information
because they can help you when you're
stuck conflicting information is a big
problem and we'll talk about it later
this happens quite often especially
initially and so Saving Time by turning
to someone close by to help explain
things to you or give you a valuable
perspective is worth hours if not weeks
and days of your time now the internet
is full of opinions so getting
conflicting information happens all the
time and some of these opinions I should
warn you would probably suggest the
opposite of what you want or where
you're headed that's okay you just need
to know when to listen and when to
ignore these opinions and that's often
easier said than done that's where
mentors can help also having a clear
line of sight with your goals and your
five ws will help you decide which
opinions to listen to and which not to
now rather than getting stuck in circles
in your head it's often just better to
talk to one of your mentors a model
who's been through that sort of
confusion before ultimately folks the
role of the mentor is to make sure that
the next step you take is the one that
takes you closer to your goal that's
what you end up using your Mentor fall
now they'll not always have the right
answers they may not even agree with you
and that's okay you need their
perspectives to test your assumptions
and your needs against your decisions
that you plan to make they will help you
make a better decision and that could
even be something as small as avoiding a
misstep or avoiding wasted time or
barking up the wrong tree something that
could derail you if they can help avoid
that they've done their job as a mentor
or a model ultimately they're there to
help you make the best choice The Best
Next Step which is much easier when
someone else has walked down the path
before they can also give you a
perspective on what they went through
and how they approach similar problems
or conundrums that's really really
valuable sometimes and I've had this a
few times they'll give you advice that
they wish they really had and and in my
opinion if someone tells you what they
wish they had had and actually gives you
what they wish they'd had that's worth
your weight and gold because they're
saving you the time and effort and money
that they may have lost and preventing
you from losing that a trusted advisor
who did what you want is really worth a
thousand times more than someone on
opinion who has never wanted what you
want or maybe wanted but never actually
tried so limit the amount of time you
take these opinions another tip Twitter
advice is just as valuable as a coffee
Meetup if it gives you the answer you're
looking for so don't be specific in the
format of the mentor
interaction the idea of a mentor
interaction is to get you the
information you need to take the next
step all right enough of this section
I'll see you in the next
video goals like work they they follow
Parkinson's law the work just expands to
fill the time available for its
completion that's just how it is so
that's why I guess people talk about
smart goal setting
smt which is an acronym and it stands
for specific me measurable achievable
realistic and time bound which is really
what this this video is about it's about
the T or the when by the time bound
aspect but to do that well you need to
ensure that you've correctly broken down
your goals so it's a little bit more
complicated than just setting a time or
when by date one very common mistake in
setting timelines for goals is that the
goals are just too large and they're
non-specific and they're not broken down
into specific pieces so for example you
could say I'm going to learn to code by
December
2019 but you won't know when you've
completed that because learning to code
is just not specific enough and arguably
the timeline is too far away setting a
far away timeline for a large goal is
kind of meaningless but it's done very
often instead you'd be much better off
breaking down the large goal into
smaller measurable goals or sub goals
that are easy to cover with metrics and
ideally there'd be a metric that you can
track and measure daily or very
frequently maybe twice a week or even
weekly some examples could be I'm going
to finish this 3-hour course by Sunday
evening then I'm going to do 2 hours of
HTML every single night so I have the
basic concepts of HTML down by the end
of the
week after that I'm going to understand
the basics of CSS with that 4-Hour Long
YouTube video and I will finish that by
Wednesday
night so the trick is to break down into
smaller chunks that are very obvious
when you've achieved them or completed
the Milestone so a tutorial is either
complete or not a video is complete or
not a section in this course is complete
when the video in that section ends
these things are clear they're clear
lines in the sand you know when you've
achieved them there's no question about
whether the goal has not been achieved
or has been achieved it's pretty binary
these kind of goals will also give you
an idea of the size of the task um which
means you can assess the time better
another thing to watch out for is it's
best not to go too far into the future
as you will Lo lose motivation
it's actually really important as a
learning strategy to give yourself lots
of quick wins constantly as that will
give you the clear sense of progress
it'll keep you motivated and energized
because you can see progress the sooner
you achieve a goal the more likely it is
you'll develop the habit of succeeding
at achieving goals because you're
constantly getting the reinforcement
feedback loop that you're achieving your
goals and one last thing for you to keep
in mind before we close out on this
video
you know sometimes life does get in the
way and it slows you down and that's
okay life happens just make sure you're
not the one slowing yourself down a
couple of videos ago we did talk about
you know off days are all right as long
as that's not the norm so similarly if
life gets in the way that's
understandable don't beat yourself up
set very hard to achieve timelines
that's important because it'll make you
more confident and focused but at the
same time if life gets in the way just
readjust those timelines a little bit
but keep the smart principles in mind
all right on to the next video okay so
in the last video we covered the fourth
W which is whenby and now in this video
we are going to talk about the fifth and
final W which is where in the context of
your learning plan where means where
you're going to learn from that is what
resources and learning formats work best
for you to achieve your learning goals I
will start by sharing with you how I
worked out my best learning format over
the years and how that
changed so back when I first tried to
learn to code it was about 2014 and muks
that's massively open online courses
which is starting to become mainstream
you can see from this chart how it was
still early days back in
2013 but back then I discovered two
things about myself one is I was used to
learning in classes and Via books
two I hadn't really considered video as
a way to teach myself and that took some
getting used to I mean I finished
University in 2003 and the world was a
very different place then Google wasn't
even listed as a public company back
then bit by bit I did start to get into
videos but I discovered that a lot of
the content was by technical people for
technical people and presumed a certain
level of prior knowledge which wasn't
that big and a friendly for someone like
me me so I found it was much easier to
just use books even though some were
slightly
outdated bit by bit though it became
very intimidating for me to see these
massive and thick books sitting on my
desk each covering a lot of content but
you know at the end of it they sort of
tell you that you've only just started
to scratch the surface so it was
visually and intellectually quite
overwhelming to have all that content
and feel like progress was incredibly
slow over time I then discovered other
resources that started to pop up really
valuable resources like free code camp
and code academy and code Avengers um
that all offered a
multimedia experience while making you
actually write some code to get a real
feel for
it over time I return back to muks
especially in places like udemy and
coera where the content had started to
mature quite a bit now by this time keep
in mind it was 2018 and I'd already quit
twice before that but between 2014 and
2017 while I kept dabbling and trying it
occasionally a lot had changed online
the quality of the content the design of
courses and also the shared number of
coders who were sharing their knowledge
openly online for free YouTube had
become a huge resource for me following
that I started to turn more and more to
tutorial sites online places like
tutorials point I even found a few us
coding boot camps that had um sites that
helped you prepare for their entrance
tests that were incredibly useful in
getting me to practice fundamental
concepts but you know all this over
those three years took a lot of trial
and error and cost me an enormous amount
of time and energy and frustration I
really think that had I had the benefit
of something like this this course that
you're doing now I would have got the
same results with onethird the wastage
of time so I'm going to give you some of
my learnings from that period in my life
steps that help me choose the best
learning formats and I really believe
that these steps are going to optimize
your path to your goal number one you
take your first learning goal or
objective and then you learn that and
Achieve that goal from different sources
so let's say for example you want to try
to learn the different types of data and
a programming language and how to assign
and recall a piece of data in a
program let's say you've even started
with Java and we'll get into choosing
the right language later on in this
course but let's say you start with Java
so what you should then do is first try
an online blog or tutorial or some form
of text learn the principles from there
then you move on to a classic textbook
and see if that works for you then you
go and listen to a podcast then maybe
watch a couple of YouTube videos and
then do it on code academy or free code
camp or you know both or what you choose
the places you want to do it from number
two when you do the same thing from so
many different resources you will find
that you get a lot of practice and
reinforcement of the principles like
these fundamentals actually get quite
firmly and trenched in your brain which
is exactly what you want but more
interestingly you're going to also have
a sense of which format was really
effective for your learning maybe you
had a urea moment while listening to a
podcast or watching a YouTube video or
you know in my case for example I found
that videos took me less time to absorb
critical information than reading a
tutorial did and I was able to
comprehend and assimilate and recall
much better when I watch videos so you
got to assess the format that works for
you not everyone is going to love videos
the way I ended up loving them towards
the end the third step number three
eliminate a few of those learning
formats by choosing only the top two
maximum three formats that actually
worked well for you once you've got your
top three two or three formats you
repeat this process all over again with
your next learning goal you try again
again but you confine yourself to those
top two or three formats keep tweaking
and measuring your results and seeing
which ones work really well for you and
you'll find the different topics um are
better covered by different resources
and you'll discover that with time and
practice what is really important here
though is for you to monitor your
learning Effectiveness over time as what
works for you today is not going to work
for you that well in 2 years if you've
evoled you'll find that you can actually
use other learning resources that today
are too hard for you but are actually
really appropriate for you in 2 years
time okay so let's quickly recap what we
learned about in this video we've talked
about different learning formats we've
talked about how some work better for
you and some may not work that well for
you how you've got to start an iterative
process of experimenting and finding out
which ones work really well for you by
choosing the same learning goal and
learning what you need to learn from
different
resources hey guys just a quick
interlude here to update for 2023 2024
figuring out out where to actually learn
from is now much harder than it was even
four years ago or 5 years ago and the
reason is you every year we double the
amount of data produced by Humanity
through digital content right so
literally every hour there are more
YouTube videos being produced that most
people can consume in a lifetime and so
what's happening is there's a lot of
noise in the system now which means it's
really hard to figure out what content
is going to be relevant for you right so
I fully recognize this is a problem some
of the previous comments I've I've
provided in the training oh it Mak come
up in later parts of this course over
and over again is figuring out what's
the difference between opinion and
advice so look out for that that section
as well but in general it's also
important to know that a lot of coding
tutorials and material are written by
coders for existing coders looking to
adopt new technologies for those of you
who've never coded before that's not
what you need to look at you will
absolutely overwhelm yourself instead
you need to be looking at coding
resources for absolute newbies who've
never coded before that's that's a
little bit harder to find and they're
also you know harder to sort of make
much progress with because they
literally cover just the beginning but
you need to layer and layer just like a
cake you need to add layers to your
learning right so look for stuff that is
not for example here's an example I once
got caught in this thing about you know
python for programmers this course right
but what I didn't realize and realize is
that the title actually kind of hints at
it it says python for programmers which
means it presumes that you're already a
program and you're trying to pick up a
new language being python right and I
was a complete beginner then I knew
nothing about programming so you know
watch out for little gotas like that and
keep in mind that the content that we
seeing out there these days is a lot of
it is open-source content which means
people without much experience or depth
or who are learning like you are writing
a lot of blogs as part of their learning
process and so that gets surfaced by
search engines or social media whatever
it is and it's not often great to learn
from to be honest right because you're
learning from people people who's s
slightly ahead of you it's it's great
that they're able to do that that
they're teaching that they're learning
by teaching which is something I
recommend doing but I don't recommend
adding to the content of the internet
generally like that like if you're going
to do it do it you know one-onone or
tell another friend or somebody else in
a small group so that you're not kind of
uh filling up the internet with stuff
that's going to come up in search
engines that may not be right having
said that keep in mind that a lot of
people producing content out there also
just learning and the content may not be
great it may not be written well well it
may not follow the pedagogical Styles
required to actually help you accumulate
the knowledge and so on you know and so
you will end up having a lot of stuff
that doesn't help you so it's really
important when you pick these resources
that you keep this in mind look for the
correct level that is yours and if in
the first three or four paragraphs it
doesn't feel like the right level
abandon it don't feel bad it just means
that it was pitched for a different
audience now I teach a lot as part of my
current role and this is an actual this
is actually a big problem from the
teacher point of view as well what level
of of person are we targeting at and if
you're not explicit about about it it
can be very confusing for other people
so it's actually a really hard problem
to solve so just recognize that you have
to be kind to yourself and to the people
prod producing content out there it's
not possible to work for everybody there
is no one siiz fits all so there's a
little bit of trial and error that's
unavoidable but it's much harder these
days to figure out the resources um that
are not curated because there's just so
much stuff there right just remember
level yourself are you an absolute
beginner or are you fairly you know
competent in the basics and accordingly
look for resources at that level and if
you're using things like chat GPT chat
GPT is quite often wrong in fact if you
sometimes challenge chat GPT even if
it's right and you say that's actually
not right it'll immediately apologize to
you so it's obviously not that confident
of in the first place so you know keep
that in mind now we've actually come to
the end of section one at this stage and
section one was only designed to help
you formulate a well structured plan
that is specific to your goals and I
think by the end of the section you
would have done that from here on we're
going to start picking apart the major
reasons why many people give up on their
plans and we want to absolutely make
sure that that does not happen to you
okay so let's keep going all right
welcome back in the last bunch of videos
we covered some really essential parts
of putting together your plan to achieve
your learning goals um in in particular
we covered things like the why the what
the where the whom and the when by that
you're going to try and put together
into your plan and all these aspects are
so essential for you to be able to
achieve your learning objectives now I'm
fairly confident in saying that by this
point of time just having that plan puts
you ahead of about 95% of your
competition because you have a solid
plan you have a solid map that helps you
navigate to your learning outcomes so
let's keep moving and now we're going to
talk about the big myths that stand in
the
way now the plan that we've put together
for you will evolve and I encourage you
to keep revisiting it for two reasons
one to check that you are following it
and that things that are going to plan
that you're tracking well to the plan
and two this is the fun bit to check
whether you've gained any new knowledge
that requires you to adjust and revise
your plan just a little bit from time to
time in the next few videos I'm going to
cover some of the top myths that
surround the process of learning to code
now let me be clear here I am not
addressing the myths of what it's like
to be a professional coder or what a
developer job is like
I'm very specifically identifying the
common myths and misconceptions that
people have about learning to code think
of it as the expectations specifically
the false expectations that people have
when they start to learn to code so why
is that important and it is really
important well it's important for three
reasons here they are one having a
picture that is false or unrealistic in
your mind can can be a major source of
frustration doubt and setbacks two mths
can make you overestimate the learning
task or underestimate it and both are
bad learning to recognize and identify
these myths will help you ask the right
questions and get the answers that are
most helpful to you remember my goal is
to save you time money and effort and
make sure that you do not fail in your
quest to become a Coda reason three
false expectations make things harder
than they need to be and doing things
the hard way is a form of waste and what
do I keep saying eliminating waste is a
very important part of succeeding at our
goals and that includes the goals of
this
course now that we understand why this
section on myths is important let's talk
quickly about why I'm covering this
material at this stage and not later
I've spent days is designing the
structure of this course so that each
section each bunch of videos prepares
you for the sections that follow the
sequence is meant to make it
exponentially easier for you to make
decisions and analyze your objectives
every step of the way so you may want to
rush ahead into other sections so that
you can start learning immediately and I
and I understand that but I would
caution you against that and I would
advise you to invest a couple of hours
now in following the structure of the
course so that you can save yourself a
few weeks of time later on I promise I
will cover some of your burning
questions for example in the next
section the next bunch of videos we will
talk about the fundamental decisions
that you need to make including for
example what language you want to start
with you will make a much better
decision if you've finished this section
though at the very very least you will
have confidence in your choice and not
be distracted by niggling doubts and
second guessing yourself about whether
your decision was arbitrary or well
informed or the right one for you so
following the sequence is important
because it then gives you the confidence
in your decision- making every step of
the way okay so we've agreed let's stick
to the courses PA and you're going to be
just fine great see you in the next
video for myth number
one welcome back in this video we're
going to talk about the first myth the
first of several myths that stand in the
way of you attaining your goals just to
be clear I'm not covering off these
myths in this section in any particular
order of importance they're just common
myths it's also very possible that you
don't believe in one or all of them but
in my experience these are some
extremely common myths that hold people
back from achieving their learning
objectives and I believe these are the
most important ones that will help you
continue down on your journey the first
myth that we are going to talk about is
whether or not computer science is the
same as coding they're not many people
do believe that you need to have a
computer science background to be a good
coder or perhaps an effective coder let
me tell you this is absolutely and
categorically not true most of the
world's coders are not computer science
graduates statistically and the reason
for this goes to the heart of the
difference between knowing how to code
and knowing the principles of computer
science here is a great summary of
it computer science is theore iCal it
takes a scientific and mathematical
approach to information and its
computation computer programming is
practical it is the process of Designing
writing testing debugging and
maintaining the source code of computer
programs they are different but related
fields so computer science is the
science of computing and includes all
stuff about the hardware the software
and theoretical capabilities and
limitations of computers whereas writing
software is simply literally writing out
the instructions to a computer so that
it can execute it that is part of the
reason why it's hard to know where the
line is that you must cross to become a
coder there is no line Beyond which you
can suddenly say hey I'm a
coder now there are computer scientists
who are fantastic at algorithms and
conceptual designs and the theoretical
side of it but who just aren't very
practiced or experienced coders and so
they're not great coders mainly because
they've only really looked at the
theoretical side of the art in fact you
can see some fairly controversial posts
on this subject on Reddit and other
forums and I've added a couple of links
in the lecture resources if you're
interested but my advice is you know
don't spend too much time asking why
that difference exists or what the
meaning of it is the only question to
ask yourself that's relevant is why does
this matter to you so it is critical to
know your what and your why to determine
if you need to have a computer science
background that's a really good thing
then that we've done that thinking right
if you want to build a blog site for
example you don't need to know much CS
if you want to build a mobile app
chances are you won't nowadays let's
face it if you want to learn data
science analytics or even intermediate
level AI you probably don't need a solid
Computer Science Background but if
you're doing Cutting Edge computing R&D
work or working for a team a startup
let's say that's optimizing scalable
technology um that's going to change the
world in some way it may help you SE it
may help separate you from the
competition if you do know a little
computer science or
CS now there is one practical case which
will immediately help you if you're
looking for jobs then it's best to do
some research into which jobs require a
CS degree here are for example two
completely random examples taken off the
internet one from the Google's career
site and the other from stack overflows
jobs listings the first one the Google
role has minimum qualifications that
require a computer science degree or
equivalent practical experience and the
preferred qualifications include a
PhD now I would guess that if you want a
job like this you're better off doing a
computer science degree it will
certainly improve your odds of getting
an interview but for the other role the
one on stack overflow jobs if you look
at it it's a full stack job and you can
see that they seem to care more about
your ability with certain languages and
Frameworks and Technologies they don't
really seem to care too much about your
formal
qualifications they seem to be more
interested in your technical ability to
execute and stuff so to be clear having
a knowledge of computer science topics
is probably helpful and probably even
makes you a better coder but it is by no
means essential certainly not essential
to learn how to code most programmers
don't have CS degrees it's just not
necessary for what they do day-to-day
with experience and time you'll start to
pick up some CS principles but that
comes later and at this stage of your
learning it's sort of thing that can
derail you unless you absolutely need it
so like I've said before give yourself
quick wins with smaller chunks and
smaller goals provided each such chunk
or goal is actually necessary to your
larger learning goal okay enough on that
let's recap quickly in this video we
covered the fundamental differences
between computer science and programming
and we've established they're not the
same thing you can be an expert in one
without knowing much about the other and
that swings both ways choosing your
learning objectives must always be done
by referring to your goals so before you
work out whether or not you need a CS
degree take a quick look at your what
and your why which are the underpinnings
of your goals and you'll know what it is
that you need to do to get there but
always always start with small chunks
that give you quick wins okay let's move
on to the next video where we're going
to cover myth number
two okay welcome back in the last video
we talked about myth number one which is
whether or not computer science and
programming are the same skill
specifically we discussed whether you
need to be a computer scientist in order
to be a good programmer in this video
we're going to talk about myth number
two which is quite similar to myth one
in the look and feel and the myth is
that you need to be great at math to Be
an Effective programmer because I'm
calling this a myth I think you know
what the answer is going to be and you
can be very relieved that the answer to
that is no you do not need to be
fantastic at math to Be an Effective
programmer unless of course your goal is
to work in a deeply theoretical and
highly technical field where the R&D or
the research and development you need to
do gets immediately applied to real
world applications and the R&D itself is
quite math heavy but that's quite a
niche area so in general to Be an
Effective coder no you don't need math
math does help to get you closer to the
computer science side of things so if
you are going to be doing computer
science then math skill definitely gives
you an advantage but my personal belief
is everything is learnable and that
includes math the reality of today's
development World though is that 99% of
s programmers do things that are based
off existing libraries where a lot of
the hard ma math is already done and
that includes really complex math heavy
subjects like data science and machine
learning artificial intelligence and so
on maybe a better question then is to
ask why math helps so it's not that you
need to have good math skills to be a
good programmer but having math skills
could really help so why is that well
one of the reasons why it could really
help is is because math teaches you to
break down problems and solve complex
problems in a structured systematic
piece by- piece way and it requires you
to hold a lot of pieces of information
sometimes competing pieces of
information in your head while you think
through it in a structured logical way
so what does that tell us maybe it's not
the knowledge of math specifically but
the ability to think logically in a
structured way that math requires that
is actually valuable as a programmer in
other words you don't need to be good at
math you need to be good at thinking
logically and in a structured way now
these skills are very very valuable as a
programmer not essential but valuable
but you will acquire them bit by bit
with more code and practice now
initially it is entirely likely that you
would be uncomfortable and feel
intimidated because you compare yourself
with people who started years before you
did now I I I made that mistake several
times I look at accomplished programmers
and you know theyve six to 10 years out
ahead of where I am and Marvel at their
ability the reality is when I was a
fairly senior lawyer new lawyers would
look at me and think that I had special
extraordinary skills and I didn't well
compared to them I did but that was only
because of experience and practice now I
can assure you that what you're going
through in terms of comparing yourself
with other people who are way ahead of
you in the path is natural and normal
maybe not the most helpful thing because
every skill is 100% learnable I've said
this before and I'll keep saying it time
and effort are the only only thing that
separate you from a goal we do live in a
culture that tells us that genius is
some innate thing I don't believe it in
fact it's scientifically invalid from
Einstein to Edison people have been
careful to point out that genius is the
result of hard work and not the cause of
any success and accomplishment if you
want to know more take a look at books
like Malcolm gladwell's outliers or Eric
Anderson's book called Peak which talks
about how people acquire Excellence but
that's a little bit of a diversion or a
little bit of a tangent to where we are
are now for now all am I saying is don't
be intimidated by math it is useful but
not essential so don't continue to
intimidate yourself with this myth you
can develop that skill if it's really
important to what you want but it may
not be so again knowing your what and
your why is critical before you can
assess whether you need a certain kind
of skill all right enough on that myth
two let's move to myth three okay
welcome back in the last video we talked
about myth number two which is whether
or not you need to be a math WIS to be a
good programmer in this video we're
going to talk about myth number three
which is extremely common and one of my
favorite myths to try and get rid of it
is that a lot of people think coding oh
that's not something I could do that's
just too hard for me let me tell you
that is absolutely an categorically not
true in fact empirically if you look
around there there are just so many
programmers in the world some as young
as 4 years old so it's obviously not too
hard for you that is just statistically
not
possible so there are three important
things to note about this myth one it is
partly true and that's what makes it so
believable two the part that is true is
that coding is
hard and three the part that is false is
that you can not do it let's break this
down
properly coding is hard but then you
know so is learning to walk and and
maybe you don't remember that so let's
try something that happened a little
later in life like learning to
write well maybe you don't remember that
either hm okay how about learning to
ride a bicycle or learning to swim
learning a second language or a third
language or learning to drive
how about learning to use Microsoft
Excel at work learning anything new is
hard and the difference is that some
things we just learn along the way so we
don't pay attention to the effort it
takes and how hard it is because we just
pick it up along the way but unless you
happen to be living with a disability
generally learning to walk write or read
or drive are things that we simply
assume we take it for granted we will
all do this one day our kids will do
this one day Etc there's nothing unusual
about these fairly complex skills and in
20 years I am 100% sure they're going to
say the same thing for coding kids in 20
years will just code like it's the most
normal thing in the world which means
coding is not hard for you it's hard for
everyone but everyone can do it so the
key here is to catch yourself when
you're thinking that it's hard
specifically for you nope it's hard for
everyone remind yourself that learning
to drive a walk is also really hard but
we take for granted we can do it and we
never doubt our ability sure some people
take a little longer they may need a
little more practice but no one really
doubts that they can do it and that
exact same attitude applies to coding
because it's a fact so let's recap
coding is hard but not just for you and
it's no harder than any other skill that
we take for granted in our modern
culture and certainly no harder than at
least two or three other skills that you
probably already have okay enough said
on that let's move on to myth number
four okay welcome back in the last video
we talked about the myth that it's too
hard for some of us to learn to code in
this video we're going to talk about an
unspoken assumption that many people
share or it's a misconception that a lot
of people don't even know that they've
fallen into which is that coding is
something that can be done very very
quickly like they show it in the movies
this is especially common for people who
want to code to build something that
they want to see in their lives or for a
startup idea they've got something that
they want to prototype quickly you know
this myth is a huge factor for the
frustration and disappointment that
cause people to give up popular media
will make us believe that you can become
a hacker quickly almost instantly with
prodigious ability and put together a
world changing protot type from your DM
room or garage in the weekend it's false
and if you don't believe me listen to
this guy movies and pop culture just get
this all wrong the idea of a single
Eureka moment is a dangerous lie it
makes us feel inadequate because we feel
like we haven't had ours yet and it
prevents people with seeds of good ideas
from ever getting started in the first
place oh and you know what else movies
get wrong about innovation
no one writes math formulas on glass
okay all right that's not a thing
okay guys even Mark Zuckerberg is
telling you that it's very dangerous to
fall into the myth of thinking that
these things happen very quickly that
you can learn or build something very
very quickly it's so dangerous that it
causes people to either not start or to
give up too early even he's saying it
and I 100% agree especially with skills
like coding it can take so much longer
than you expect that if your
expectations are too false you run the
real risk of giving up I cannot
emphasize this enough and I do not want
you guys to give up because of
mismatched expectations and that's why
this myth is so important do not think
that it's going to be quick instant and
glorious it is really not but it is
totally possible with time and effort
okay so apart from pop culture
and the myth of the weekend entrepreneur
you also have significant marketing
effort being put into telling you that
you can learn to code in a weekend or 4
hours or 10 hours or whatever it is some
will say that you will be job ready in 3
months and technically they're right but
it is slightly
misleading most coders learn by doing
and if you don't do that thing that
you're learning again for a little while
you will forget it in other words you
need to keep repeating and keep doing
more of it in order for it to get
entrenched in your
memory so you can absolutely learn the
basics in a month maybe two or three
depending on how much time you're
putting into it and how much focused
energy you're putting into
it the key message here though is to be
prepared that whatever the timelines
you're being sold on what they're not
telling you is how much time you've got
to put in per day to achieve that
timeline and that's what you need to
factor in coding takes a lot of time now
you never actually stop learning to code
but that's partly because coding takes
so much more time than you expect and
because it takes so much more time you
learn for much longer periods of time as
you wait through it so if you do happen
to think that you're going to Learn
Python in two weeks and build a an email
or Twitter bot in the week after you
absolutely could by copying it from a
tutorial and working your way through
that but it's not really meaningfully
learning the actual skill of what you're
putting together you're just copying it
from a tutorial and lots of people
confuse the ability to build an
application with actually learning to
program they they're slightly different
things it's very easy to follow a
tutorial and build a program and you
will learn a little bit from doing that
but the real real learning comes from
getting royally St stuck and getting
unstuck can take a lot of time but
believe me that's where you do most of
the learning where you have the Eureka
moments that really make the penny drop
and the lesson drive home so coding is
not something you can learn very quickly
you can absolutely learn the basics
fairly quickly but you need to practice
it to become good and the best learning
unfortunately happens when you get stuck
and when you get stuck it takes a lot of
time to get unstuck therefore the best
learning which happens out of getting
stuck takes a lot of time because
getting unstuck takes time and I hope
you see that logic there so let's recap
quickly you can absolutely learn to code
well and learn to program a computer
very well over time you get faster at
picking up new things the more you learn
and as more time goes on but inherently
it's not a quick process so do not set
yourself up for failure with
unreasonable expectations that you can
read a textbook and build your startup
this weekend okay I'll see you in the
next and final myth okay welcome back in
this video we're going to cover the last
myth for now myth number five is the
last myth at the moment but I want you
to know that I will be looking very
closely at the information I keep
getting especially from information from
people like you as to other myths that
should be added to this section because
this section will have all the content I
can find on the myths that need to be
dispelled so if you know of other myths
that you think affects a lot of people
please do let me know this section will
keep growing to accommodate those mths
because my goal continues to be and will
always be to try and remove as many
obstacles as I can from your path to
learning how to code and myths are a
huge obstacle they really do set a lot
of people back so if you have ideas
please do let me know um but keep coming
back to the section to see if anything
more has been added because I hope to
add a lot more to this all right let's
keep going to the rest of myth
five okay so the last myth that that
we're going to cover for now is that
coding is boring and
geeky a lot of Pop Culture will have you
believe that coding is for just the
Nerds and the Geeks and the socially
inept but we I think now we can all
accept that that's not true anymore as
Steve Jobs said everyone should know how
to program a computer because it teaches
you how to think so if thinking is
boring and geeky then we do have bigger
problems as a society I guess but if you
think that think is important then
learning to code just makes you better
at something that you already know is
important on a more practical note
however coding is extremely creative in
that sense it is an art that lets you
create in software what doesn't happen
easily in the physical world from gaming
to music to Art to entertainment shows
to helping people with disability using
software to improve and shape the world
around you is very powerful ful and very
very creative software is absolutely
just a tool it's just like an artist's
paintbrush or a sculptor's chisel you
use it to shape the world around you and
to give form to the ideas and
Imagination in your head today your
imagination can be converted to reality
through code something that for the M
for the vast history of mankind we
couldn't do what makes coding really
special is that it's not just an art it
is extremely extremely practical and it
requires you to constantly solve
problems some problems are hard some
problems are just really unusual and
interesting but the science does show
unequivocally that solving problems
gives the brain a chemical rush and
lights up all the reward centers in your
brain so quite literally solving good
problems makes people happier and more
fulfilled and coding is all about
solving problems now imagine doing
something that makes you happier the
more you do it that doesn't sound like
work at all right so if the popular
narrative is that coding is for geeks
well try it out for yourself lots of
cool people code the world has never
loved coders more and to top it all off
it's highly creative deeply satisfying
and good for you mentally and
emotionally and it puts you in a flow
state so if you want a code be proud of
it go for it it's fantastic just keep
going and don't hold yourself back
because of these kind of myths and
falsehood okay welcome back um we're now
at the last video of this section for
now I know we've had a big section going
through all the myths and the
misconceptions that often can bring us
down and derail us in our approach to
coding I know some of you may not want
to hear this right now and I know you
may not even really be ready for this
but I would strongly encourage you to
pause for about 15 to 20 minutes now and
revisit the goals and plan that you had
put together at the end of section one
if you remember section one was all
about the five ws and how that
influences your goal setting and on the
back of which you can build a proper
plan now is a good time to go back and
revisit that revisit that plan because
now that you've understood the mths and
false expectations that often
subconsciously influence our decision-
making you may see maybe you won't but
you may see that your plan and goals
reflect those false assumptions those
false expect expectations and those
myths if they do now is a great time to
revise your plan and goals taking into
account what you've learned in this
section about mths and removing those
mths from your plan the benefit of that
is it makes your plan much more strong
and much more achievable for you and I
know I've hopped on this several times
so far in this course but it's really
important that your goals are robust so
that that reduces the ODS that you're
going to fail or give up that is very
very important remember it's one of our
shared goals goals on this program so go
back and do that now for about 10 or 15
minutes if you need to adjust your plan
to reflect what you've learned in the
section go ahead and do it and take the
time to do it right very importantly if
you found some myths or expectations had
crept into your plan and goal setting I
would really love for you to share that
in the Q&A with your peers help your
peers to see what you saw after coming
this far in the course and maybe that'll
help them revisit their plan that will
also help them learn what you have
learned likewise you can learn from
others who've shared on the forums so
this makes it a much richer experience
for all of us and I personally would
absolutely love to see things through
your eyes and read about your experience
revisiting your plan in the forums
because I think that will help me make
this an even better course for you to
return to all right well I'll see you in
the next section cuz it's going to be
fun so in this section what I'd like to
talk to you guys about is some of the
big gotchas right these are things that
are really high risk factors and this
wasn't actually this section wasn't
there in the original course and the
reason I added it is in the last you
know 3 or four years I've coached
several hundred students on career
change to code and I've noticed a few
patterns and these patterns are what I
call the risk factors okay so I want to
cover them all with you because you're
going to get the benefit of all the work
I've done over the last four years with
hundreds of students and you're going to
see the main reasons why people fail
especially in either learning to code or
career change which you know are two
different things so in identifying these
risk factors they're like potholes on
the road or big you know barricades in
the middle of the road and so by knowing
them in advance your forearmed is for1
right or is it the other way around for
wand is forearmed that's what the
correct way of the of saying it is so
now that you have the knowledge in
advance you're able to actually avoid
the problem so the let's start here the
the the biggest RIS factors there are a
number of of them and I'm going to
classify them by different types the
first type is avoidant behaviors right
and even within this there are broadly
two categories the first is you actually
know what you need to do you know it you
don't like it you don't you may not want
to do it but you know what you have to
do and yet you don't do it and very
often these can be things like actually
putting in the time required or very
commonly not jumping around from one
resource to the other not abandoning
things in the middle right sticking with
it till the end even if you're really
not having fun with it but as long as
it's moving you closer to your goal now
often the excuse will come up hey I
don't actually know this is moving me
closer to your my goal and you need to
have the self-awareness to distinguish
between an excuse and a reason often we
use excuses and make them look like
reasons and all we're trying to do is
avoid the situation so avoiding
behaviors category one is knowing what
you should do but still not doing it
anywhere the second type of avoidant
behavior is sticking within your comfort
zone which when you start to think about
it is kind of evidence in the first one
as well how did this show up it means
that you don't want to learn something
new because you're struggling with it or
you don't want to ask questions on stack
Overflow because you're worried about
rejection or you don't want to ask
another coding friend that your friend
who codes because you're afraid of what
their judgment will be with you or you
don't want to announce to the world that
hey this is my intention this is what
I'm going to do uh you guys can laugh at
me or think I'm crazy or encourage me
whatever you do I know that this is what
I want to do and I'm going to do it but
that takes obviously a certain amount of
coverage and a certain amount of
willingness to be outside your comfort
zone so if you stick within your comfort
zone what ends up happening is you only
take the actions that you're already
comfortable doing but we know has not
already produced the results you want
and if you keep repeating the things you
already have done before but expect a
completely different outcome you're
going to be disappointed right so part
of sticking or not sticking in your
comfort zone is to take actions that
you've never done before even if they're
deeply uncomfortable and using that as a
learning experience and one way to think
about that is as an old saying I I don't
fail I lie I either succeed or I learn
now you may argue the semantics of that
but there's a very powerful message in
there which is your attitude to the
outcome is what will determine the value
of that outcome to you you can either
view to view you can choose to view it
as successful or a failure or you can
choose to view it as successful and a
learning experience or you can choose to
experience it or view something as just
failure in which case you're very likely
to put yourself in a negative emotional
state and discourage yourself from
trying again now the other typ types of
R risk factors are what I call the five
un estimation and there are five big
ones the first one is underestimating
yourself typically things like I'm not
good at math I'm not good at this I'm
not good at that the fixed mindset kind
of stuff which is an underestimation of
yourself I firmly believe that we're all
human beings we're all fundamentally the
same and we all have practically for all
practical purposes unlimited
intellectual potential if we put in the
time and the effort right that's not
true for everybody I agree but usually
if you're kind of above average
intelligence or even if you're above if
you're just at average intelligence
you're still capable capable of as much
as somebody who you would consider super
high IQ right I see no correlation
between that and a lot of successful
people are a pretty average intelligence
in fact I dare dare say that if you're a
little bit honest with yourself and I've
thought about this a lot in my life
people who are less smart either at
school or college or you know whatever
subject or less talented than you have
possibly overtaken you career-wise or
financially or emotionally whatever you
know metric you use and that just goes
to show that just having the RO Talent
the ability is not enough you need to uh
correctly um align yourself with your
goal and then just go for it and believe
in yourself so underestimating yourself
is a major major risk factor the second
is underestimating the path that you're
going to be on like look I I remember I
once went for a hike here in Australia
and I did not read the weather fast
carefully and it was actually snowing on
top of the mountain and I was in shorts
now as you can imagine I was terribly
underprepared for that right I had all
the information I needed I just didn't
bother to look at it properly I was
Reckless I was actually careless and so
when I was there I really suffered quite
acutely and so underestimating the path
will cause a lot of problems a lot of
failure and worst in in things like it's
one thing to climb a mountain it's
another thing to to en Endeavor on a
thing like career change or learning a
complex new skill that moves very fast
this coding moves really fast is if you
underestimate the path and you encounter
problems that are expected but you think
they're not you're going to blame
yourself you're going to think you're
not smart enough you're not you're not
work you're not cut out for it you're
never going to be able to compete you're
going to blame yourself even though what
you're going through is actually quite
normal right now the third thing is
underestimating the time it takes to get
it Mastery most people make the mistake
of thinking I'll learn a bit of HTML and
CSS and some JavaScript and I will then
be
employable that's not true because the
reality is that's like saying I know a
little bit of English so now I can go
and be a judge right these are just the
tools the language whether it's HTML CSS
Java JavaScript Scala whatever you want
to call it python whatever these are
just tools right and I've often said
this on LinkedIn that your job is is not
learn how to play a musical instrument
like using a musical metaphor your job
is to know how to create music that
people want nobody cares what instrument
you use really at the end of the day and
so if you want to get Mastery level at a
given instrument it's going to take a
lot of time and to be employable you
need to have Mastery level you don't
need to be the world's foremost expert
not at all but you need to have a
professional standard of skill without a
professional standard of skill why would
anyone employ you to do this
professionally right you're not an
amateur you need to be a professional
level of skill now the next thing is
underestimating the competitive
landscape which kind of links in a bit
with the previous point which is you're
competing with professionals you may be
at an amateur level you can't compete
with a professional when you're at an
amateur level right so set the goal
correctly don't underestimate the kind
of time it's and effort it's going to
take to get to professional levels of
skill and then optimize to get there as
fast as you can and do not underestimate
the competitive landscape as a career
changer in my late 30s I realized that
most of my competitors were probably 10
to 15 young years younger than me my
bosses were all going to be younger than
me which turned out to be true and still
is and so you need to understand that
these are people who've been there 105
years ahead of you you've been coding
for 10 15 20 years some of them have
been coding since they were you know 13
or 14 and they're 5 years younger than
you or they were in my case and there's
no way I could actually expect to beat
them in an interview all I could do is
be a better cand it which is you know a
completely different skill so you have
to correctly estimate the competitive
landscape and realize that every day
hundreds of people with no background
still get their opportunities whether
it's in coding or some other job or
architecture or Law whatever it is you
know people without experience get
opportunities every day so why not you
the question is not is it possible of
course it is because it happens hundreds
of times every day the question is how
is it how do you make it possible for
yourself right and you start by not
making any of these five
underestimations now the sixth
underestimation is the process of just
drisking yourself and this is because
and I I banged on about this quite a lot
on LinkedIn is as as candidates our
entire worldview is us us us us it's a
very me Centric worldview I'm a
candidate I'm looking for a job I want
to be a coda I'm trying to change my my
career and the market doesn't really
care right because the market views you
as one of many Alternatives that it has
to choose from and there's a transaction
you give me your services and skill and
I'll pay you you know x amount of
dollars every year to do that right so
that's what the market thinks about you
on the other hand are thinking hey I
need a job hey I've got to put food on
the table hey I've taken all this risk
hey I've got a family hey I've got you
know all this time that that I could be
spending in my other care you're going
through all that so you have to
understand that in the eyes of the
market a career changer is much more
risky than someone who's not a career
changer someone with no no experience is
way more risky than someone with a bit
of experience and so when you are
presenting yourself to the market to try
and change career and get a job as a
coda or in fact any other career you
have to understand how you're viewed as
a risk and then systematically drisk
yourself in the eyes of the hiring
manager right and if you underestimate
what that takes no matter learning code
algorithms and data structure is going
to help you because you're still going
to appear risky to the to the person and
keep in mind learning a lot of code
doesn't help if you don't have a single
interview right it's like being all
dressed up with no no date right to go
with so you want to make sure that
you're not just learning to code but
you're also presenting yourself in the
market in a way that makes you
attractive to employeers and that's how
you drisk yourself in the market now
some of the other risk factors we talked
about this a little earlier is the wrong
expectations right look without setting
the right expectations you are going to
experience what could be a normal
friction or a normal setback or a normal
failure as a very serious permanent sort
of failure okay so in in one of the
previous videos I talked about you know
how to set goals achieve the goals chunk
them down right so if you look at the
video on on on how to do a when by
learning go objective or learning goals
you know when by is better than you know
do by dates and stuff like that in that
video I talked about chunking things
down so that's a good example of how of
an opportunity to to set the right
expectations when you chunk things down
you have to understand and set
expectations with yourself about you
know how long is this going to take how
much effort is it going to take every
day how's it going to feel when I'm
struggling and I don't have any support
and I'm I can't understand something and
is that normal is that part of the
process it's like if you go you know to
the gym for the first time in your life
and no one tells you that your muscles
are going to hurt the next day you're
going to think you've done damage to
yourself right and actually no that's a
normal and healthy proof of the fact
that you're on the right path is cuz you
achy muscles the next day but if you had
no idea that was going to be the case
you would very legitimately expect that
hey maybe I've injured myself
permanently and you'll be afraid of the
gym right so you have to have the right
expectations and one of them is also
definitely not expecting recruiters to
bang down your door just because you
know some HTML or css or you know
JavaScript or Java whatever like they're
not going to be banging down in the door
recruiters are looking for the best most
experienced candidate they can get for
the least price okay that's the nature
of the marketplace that's exactly what
you would do if you went you know
looking for a a lawyer or an accountant
or a teacher or a coach You' look for
the best value you can get for the
cheapest price and that's exactly what
hiring managers and and recruiters are
doing so don't expect them to bang down
your door instead communicate your value
right so having right expectations on
what each step of your journey feels
like even when you chunk it down is
absolutely critical now a lot of people
say oh you know I know coding is meant
to be hard it's not easy and they say it
like an abstract concept yeah of course
it's not easy I don't expect this to be
easy okay do you expect it to be hard
yes I expect it to be hard but what does
that mean what does hard mean in
practice what is the actual day-to-day
experience of doing something hard feel
like and typically it is I don't know
what to do next I have no I don't
understand what I'm studying right now
my code doesn't work this algorithm of
data structure makes zero sense to me
I'm not able to communicate the solution
I cannot build an application I don't
even know where to start I don't know if
I'm in the right direction if only I had
a plan all of these things that you're
going through are normal because that's
Frank L what happens when you do hard
things all these doubts happen right and
especially self-d am I good going to be
good enough I'm not good enough in math
am I going to be able to smart enough be
smart enough to convince the hiring
manager all of that doubt that emotional
battle the fear that you have to battle
that's kind of part of what hard things
are that is exactly what hard things are
meant to feel like that is what hard
means is that emotionally intellectually
physically certainty wise it's a very
hard problem to solve that's what hard
means right so having the right
expectation when you say yeah I know
this is going to be hard understand that
that's really what it means for a long
period of time and you don't know when
that's going to end you honestly don't
right you just had to keep going until
you get closer and and you know having
the right expectations on time is also
critical right we talked about in this
in the in the previous risk factor if
you have the wrong expectations about
how long some things are going to take
you're going to switch first thing
you're going to do is you're going to
say this resource is not right for me
this person is not right for me uh this
language is not right for me uh this
career is not right for me Etc things
are going to to take time the the
challenge is this is why it gets hard is
you don't know how much time is actually
reasonable right and so that's why
taking having no wrong expectations
about the time my general rule is not
just about coding guys about everything
in life is you have a secret hope that
it's going to take you x amount of time
triple it and if you're not willing to
do three to four times more time than
how what you secretly hope it's going to
be don't even start because you're just
going to give up right but if you're
willing to say okay I hope this is going
to happen in let's say you know 2 months
but if it doesn't happen in in 6 months
or if it doesn't happen in 12 months
then I know there's a problem but if it
doesn't happen in 2 months okay maybe I
just underestimated you know so don't
have these arbitrary deadlines make sure
that you have the right expectations in
terms of how long it's going to take
right the next one really important
these days in 2023 onwards do not go by
social media and chat gbd okay neither
of them are going to help you change
career nor are they going to help you
learn to code these are tools now of
course this is going to be
controversial can you learn how to do
something using chat GPD and some
influence on social media sure you can
learn how to do something from anybody
right because you can always learn
something that's not the yard stick the
art stick is is this actually going to
take you significantly closer to your
goal such that investing your time in it
is a Justified investment right now chat
GPD is just a big AI tool it's just
going to you know do statistical
averages and spit out responses and I
can tell you I I've been using AI in my
coding job for over a year now well
before CHD became a really big thing and
I can tell you it is often wrong enough
that I need to spend some time figuring
out what to do with it or it's more
right when I ask it a better question
which by the way is exactly what Google
was like right it's just that it's basic
chat basically I would say is a very
advanced Google Search right now now in
the future it could do things um that
you know we currently can't do and in
the future AI will replace fairly
repetitive things maybe I don't know you
know maybe like CSS or HTML or some you
know data analysis I don't know it could
replace any number of things I actually
think it's going to replace things in
the medical profession and the legal
profession like it's going to replace
some things in a lot of professions but
that doesn't mean jobs are going to go
all it means is jobs are going to
require slightly different skills so
jobs won't go down jobs which AI takes
over may not exist anymore but that's
always been how it was right there was a
time when you'd have char charers around
in the street all the time and then you
had showers and now you just drive
yourself right like that's just how
things are it's not that the jobs go
away or the need goes away it's that the
nature of the skill will change and
that's where you can absolutely get an
advantage is by being ahead of the curve
in terms of what skills are going to be
need it right so Social Media Chat gbd
don't go by the expectation set by them
here's my general rule if somebody gives
you a point of view and they haven't
done what you're trying to do it's an
opinion at best okay and advice can only
come from someone who's actually done
what you're trying to do everything else
is an opinion so use that sort of mental
model to figure out who to listen to
online and chat whatever it is that
you're using all right now uh the other
wrong expectation is that your recruit
is are going to be interested in you
just because you know how to code no cuz
frankly there are hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of people in every city
that know how to code and who are also
competing for the same job as you so the
way to get recruited interest is not
simply to show that hey I've learned a
little bit of you know HTML JavaScript
CSS python whatever no you got to get
recruiter interest by showing that
you're highly employable with the skills
you have because you can solve real
problems that the recruiter's clients or
the company needs to solve which means
you got to know a lot more about the
company and this is for career changes
specifically it's a different thing if
you're coming out of uh college and you
have recruitment on campus or you know
you've got some internships lined up and
that's how you're going to get the job
that's different right cuz they already
know you the hardest thing is getting
the first interview not passing the
interview is also hard but what's the
point of preparing to crack the coding
interview if you don't have a single
interview right so how to get interviews
how to get recruiter interest in a
competitive Marketplace is something
that you should not have the wrong
expectations about it's hard you're
competing with people that look way
better than you on paper so the question
is how do you show value how do you show
you can do the job without doing the
same thing that everybody's doing right
you got to not just stand out you got to
stand apart like one of my recruited
friends Dave he he mentioned this stand
apart not just stand out right and there
are ways to do that you just got to
figure out what works for you and get
the right help in terms of the right
guidance if that's what you need
now a common question I get is and it's
sort of linked to the expectation stuff
is how do I know this is going to work
right how do I know this is going to
work well you don't the short answer is
you don't you have it's exactly like a
business you don't you have a good hunch
of the products going to be great you're
going to be able to you know sell it
well in the market but you don't know
and typical like any other startup it's
iterative you try something works
doesn't work you get some feedback you
improve it the next time and you keep
you know cycling through that now
there's a guy called Alex harosi who you
know who's an entrepreneur that I
followed for a few years and you know I
find him quite interesting the way he
thinks and like I said most of the
lessons I learned that helped me change
code actually came from my startup and
Entrepreneurship years right it wasn't
from theod in fact I got some of the
worst advice I ever got from computer
science folks or from people who' only
ever been in one career which is coding
like the serious I did you know coding
in in college I've been a professional
quter for the last 10 years some of
those folks they didn't mean badly but
they just gave me some of the worst
advice that I actually ended up
receiving because they didn't know what
career change is all about now this guy
is an entrepreneur I was an entrepreneur
in in a past life so I understand where
this is coming from and this is true of
business this is true of career change
also right generally if a thing is not
working there are three reasons
okay and you have to know you have to
know which bucket it falls into one is
you're pursuing the wrong opportunity
right a bad opportunity whether it's
business or the career like let's apply
this to coding well coding is not a bad
opportunity we know that of all the jobs
out there in the world today it's
probably going to be just like every
other job slightly affected by AI but
probably not that affected because every
business needs take that's not going to
go away right every business is going to
run on software that's not going to go
where right and so we know it's a great
opportunity we know there's plenty of
potential certainly more than most other
careers out there there's plenty of
potential okay in my view so we know
it's not a bad opportunity okay what are
what are the other reasons it could be
failing well you've got a bad plan or
you're executing it really badly right
so right opportunity with a bad plan and
terrible execution it's just like the
right business idea is not going to work
and the last thing is impatience which
goes down to having the wrong
expectations if you're being impatient
not giving it the time it's going to
take and it normally organically will
take you're going to think this is not
working when all it means is it's not
working yet because it hasn't taken the
time now the analogy that a lot of
people you know would would understand
here is no matter how much you fertilize
and water of seed it's going to take a
certain amount of time to germinate
become a plant grown under a tree right
no matter how much you water it or
fertilize it it's not you can't rush
that process Beyond a point you can't
skip the steps it's kind of the same
with career change it's going to take
the time it takes same thing with
learning how to Cod to a Mastery level
or professional level it's going to take
the time it takes you cannot skip the
steps being impatient is going to make
you think you're failing right so these
are the three reasons we know it's not
we know that coding is not a bad
profession we know that coding careers
aren't really going anywhere we know
that with the right expect uh execution
and plan people like me and others have
been able to make the change and we know
that impatience is another Factor that's
going to trip you up so try and avoid
each of these three factors Factor one
is not a real thing for you guys in in
in in coding but you know the the next
to bad execution bad plan and impatience
are very real things right now let me
talk and I know I've been sort of
running through this quite fast but the
next thing I'd like to mention is that
that there are three currencies that we
need to think about right because there
are really three currencies any of us
have we're all born with this in varying
degrees okay all all three all of them
we're all born with some am of it but
they're varying degrees right and so
there are three investable resources or
three currencies one is money the other
is time and the third is energy right we
all have these three think of them as
three knobs on a music system if you
like that you're dialing like bass
treble and volume or whatever you want
right and so these are three things that
we have all of us in varying degrees and
we have to invest invest them we cannot
avoid it every single day of our life we
spending or investing these three things
in varying degrees okay now there's a
big difference between a cost or an
expenditure and an investment an
investment is something that has a
reasonable likelihood of giving you some
gain back okay this is why a car is
never an investment right it's always an
expenditure because you're always going
to lose money on a car once you buy it
and then it's always going to go down in
value however it has a lot of value to
you because it'll help you transport but
it's not an investment now you can take
education as a classic example of a
really great investment there the JW is
out there about whether traditional
college education still is or not but
you know I think most of us agree that
having gone to some kind of college is
probably better than not having gone to
a college it may not have given us
everything we wanted but that could have
also been wrong expectations or a wrong
plan but it's better that we educated
than we not it's better to have some
college degree or some high school
education than to not right so those are
also kinds of Investments now the three
unavoidable ones right money time energy
you have to invest these three guys you
have to invest these three and my
suggestion is um we always value the
thing we have least right which is why
you know people with plenty of money who
are very successful businessmen or
entrepreneurs or CEOs or whatever they
have lots of money and they don't have
enough time so they will spend a lot of
money to save time right they will spend
a lot of money to save time and you know
when people don't have money they spend
a lot of time to to avoid having to
spend money right so that's just the way
it is so that's why some people can fly
and some people will take the train
right it's one person has more money
than time the other person has more time
than money that's generally how it is so
there's a little bit of a dilemma again
from the business world that comes in
here in general and this is called the
business tremma it's also true in
software engineering project delivery
it's also true in most things in life
and definitely in career change
education skill development and so on
you kind of have to choose between three
things okay two out of three things
because you have those three resources
money energy and time now you have a
dilemma you can choose two out of the
three things on the screen right you can
it can either be good and fast good and
cheap or fast and cheap it cannot be all
three and so this means you have to
choose how to invest your resources
right if you want it good and fast it's
probably not going to be cheap and and
you know you can go through all the
other combinations in this trilemma
right so think about the resources you
have in your hands now just because
someone else went to Computer Science
school doesn't mean you have to just
because someone else taught themselves
for free and took four years doing it
doesn't mean you have to use the
resources you have everybody has some
resources that they have in some
combination of these three okay time
money and energ use the resources you
have don't be afraid to invest all three
if you need to to get ahead and save you
know save the time or save the money
whatever it is that you're saving okay
if you're working full-time then energy
is also at a premium right would you
save spend a little bit of money to save
a bit of energy maybe right that's what
exactly what you do anytime you take
public transport instead of ride instead
of walking is you're spending money to
save time and energy right so use your
three resources as best you can you
don't I'm not saying go crazy and you
know spend all your time doing something
and spend all your money I'm just saying
don't be afraid to spend the resources
you have CU everybody has these three
resources in different points right and
you need to accept that there's a
trade-off there's a very very real
trade-off now for example I'm a big fan
of free code Camp I you know learned a
little bit of the basics when I started
out free code Camp you know I I really
have written a lot for free Cod Camp
because I really believe it's an
incredibly valuable resource and all
that and it's free right it's very very
good in my opinion it's not necessarily
the fastest way you can do how do I know
this because well people choose to go to
boot camps in 3 months they could do it
probably faster if they were you know
working part part time or full-time now
I have other views on boot camps and
stuff cuz it may not work for everybody
but the point is just because something
is free doesn't necessarily mean it's
the right thing for you or inversely
just because something is fast doesn't
mean it's going to get you the result in
a quality way or just because something
is expensive doesn't mean it's going to
be good you have to figure out what's
the right combination for you
okay right ch two out of three like I
said now there's one say that this guy
Ben Franklin once said which really
really affected me in fact it drove a
lot of my investments in my mid-30s in
myself and education and getting better
and self-development and stuff and he
said if you think education is expensive
try ignorance right and it's really true
it's really really true we're so aware
of the fact that you know things will
cost us time money or energy or things
aren't easy but think about this not
doing it is probably going to be much
worse right so if you think something's
expensive whether it's time money or
energy expensive in any other way
emotionally whatever it is then try not
think about what not having it is going
to cost you as well right that's the
main lesson from this thing now let me
quick quickly recap the major risk
factors we've talked about we talked
about the fact that hard things are
really hard and we need to accept what
hard actually means every day in
granular detail on a day-to-day basis
right understand what that actually
feels like in person we've talked about
the fact that if you know what to do
well then maybe do it if you're not
doing it cuz often That's a classic risk
factor you you know what action to take
but you don't take the action right and
the other thing is you need to be living
on the edge of your comfort zone if not
slightly outside it not too far outside
but certainly slightly outsid it because
that's where the growth is going to
happen and that's where you're going to
learn what you need to learn to expand
your own Horizons inside your comfor
Zone you're not going to expand your
horizons all right next is we talked
about the three different types of
currencies the investable resources that
everybody has which is time energy money
and everybody has them in different
varying degrees so invest what you've
got heavily right and don't hold
yourself back from investing other
things just because you think it's going
to be hard inconvenient costly you don't
like to lose whatever it is really think
about your investable resources and
think like a CEO or an investor or
Finance person and say I've got these
finite resources I want to double my
resources how do I do it right that's
why people spend money to save a lot of
time that's why people go to college
because they could do it themselves but
it's probably going to take them five
years instead of three years and that
two years is you know worth $200,000 to
them or $300,000 to them so think about
the cost of not doing something not just
the cost of doing something in terms of
time energy and money your three big
investable resources and the third is
accept that no matter what choice you
make they're going to be trade-offs
right be very clear on the trade-offs
very very clear on the trade offs so
that you're emotionally comfortable with
them when you make them right if you're
going to spend money for something
accept that you're going to spend money
and there's a risk that you may not get
all that you hoped out of it the
question is are you going to lose the
money not really you're going to learn
something it may not be everything that
you hope for right or you're going to
spend you're going to save the money but
you going to put the dream at big risk
because it could take 5 years and you
could give up along the way that's what
I see happening most often or you could
you know try and take a shortcut and say
I'm going to do you know this thing
because somebody said I could do this in
90 days and I'm going to do that and I'm
going to spend money on doing it in 90
days and then you've but you don't
aren't actually willing to put in the
time and the energy you're willing to
put in the money and you're willing to
you know Let it go as fast as it'll go
but you're not willing to invest the
time and the energy into it and you're
trying to take a shortcut that won't
work either so accept the tradeoffs for
everything you do right so you know
learn to sell the difference between EX
expending a resource and investing it
and finally remember that even though
coding is a great career for many you
know it's not that there's something
wrong with the coding career if you're
not making progress so it's not that
there's something wrong with you it
could be that you have the wrong
expectations it could be that your
plan's not right it could be that you're
not executing the plan correctly or it
could just be that you're being too
impatient right I'm not saying it's easy
to know I'm just saying really think
hard about which one this is because
it's more likely to be that than the
fact that you're not smart enough or
that coding is not the right thing for
you those are very rare actually to be
hon Hest it's much more often the
combination of wrong expectations
impatience and bad plan okay so that's
it for the big risk factors I'll see you
in another video okay welcome back in
this section we're going to talk about
some of the fundamental decisions that
you have to make as you start your
journey to code now these decisions are
quite important but I do want you to
understand that there are no perfectly
right universally accepted right
decisions to be made but there are wrong
decisions and when I say wrong what I
mean is that they're costly to you some
decisions can cost you a lot of wasted
effort time and money and we want to
avoid these things because they're
sources of discouragement and
demotivation keep in mind that this
course is meant for people who have
started their journey and also for those
who've never even come close to coding
before so in this section in the next
bunch of videos we will cover some
fundamentals as viewed from the
perspective of someone who has never
touched code
before while I say these decisions are
fundamental the reason I say that is
because they're just starting points and
very important critical starting points
on your journey to code but don't be
fooled into thinking that that makes
them difficult these are not
intrinsically hard decisions but they
can be confusing and that's why a lot of
people get tripped up and frustrated by
this process and an enormous amount of
energy and time is wasted on some of
these fundamental decisions which later
Pro to be Irrelevant in the larger
scheme of things for example we're going
to cover fundamental things like
choosing a programming language that's
right for you what is an IDE and which
one should you try and use does it even
matter or identifying skills that match
your objectives so that you can be
focused on what really matters which is
achieving your goal unfortunately though
I cannot make these decisions for you
but I can give you the tools and insight
that you need to make really smart
decisions okay great let's get started
the stack Overflow insights page which
has the summary of the developer survey
results from 2018 more
than 100,000 developers told us what
they enjoy Etc so let's go down to
technology and it tells us here we go
most popular
Technologies well javascript's right up
there this is all respondents let's take
a look at professional developers Ah
that's also JavaScript so you can see
that web development seems to be
especially front-end when web
development seems to here too the
majority for uh professional and coders
generally a lot of them seem to like
these Technologies and they're the most
popular now that's probably just a Sher
count just the share numerical value of
how many people want to do these
languages let's see what's at the bottom
of the list Pearl not a very popular
language you know Swift Ruby type script
Les somewhere in the middle C++ appears
to be more popular Python's quite High
Java is very high SQL you know database
now you may not you don't need to know
all of these languages that's really
important to know but what I'm trying to
say here is you can reasonably infer
that a really popular language is likely
to have a lot of support around it for
example a lot of easily accessible
material now let's also look at it from
the point of view of which language is
popular from the industry's point of
view you know from an industry demand
point of view so we can take a look at
well top paying is one way to do it
let's quick take a quick look at most
loved Reddit and wanted cuz I find that
quite
funny so we see the most loved language
is rust um most dreaded language is
Visual Basic and these are interesting
things to know not necessarily directly
relevant for your decision to choose a
language I'd go with the most popular
Technologies and then look at the top
paying and see if that matches to your
goals if it doesn't you need to have
some real hard thinking about what
matches to your goal so in terms of the
indry demand which language is there a
lot of demand for one way to look at it
as well which ones pay the top dollar
for so this could just be because
there's a lot of demand for these but
not enough Supply but it may not be a
general purpose sort of language it
could be quite specific and Niche and
therefore may not be suited to your
learning goals but it's interesting to
see here that the top pain Technologies
are languages like FSH and O camel
closure groovy and pearl which was you
know not what not a favorite language
but quite in demand and if you scroll
down to the bottom you'll see JavaScript
HTML and CSS are you know not associated
with the highest salaries in fact
they're probably the lowest salaries and
the reason is there's probably a ton of
Supply at that area nothing wrong with
that it also means that there's probably
a lot of jobs there just may not be high
paying jobs so that looks at it from the
demand point of view now let's have a
think about how do we find beginner
friendly language as well there's not a
great deal here that talks about that
opinion so I'll just go to Google and
say
um beginner
friendly oh there you go programming
language and we'll just start with this
entry which is just an except that
Google gives me which talks about well
JavaScript python
Ruby what what else do they have at this
coded Dojo site I'm just clicking on the
first one that came up so this
JavaScript python Ruby Java not sure
what block lay is um but these are
really apparently they consider them to
be uh the top five programming languages
it's a bit dated but I don't think too
much has changed it's fair to say
JavaScript Python and Ruby and Java are
still very very popular beginner
languages uh I think that's fair to say
so that's one way you could go about
identifying well what's popular what's
not what do you want to do try and map
it to your goals but have a really good
think about making sure it aligns with
your goals because it's not it's not
important to go by what these stats say
if it's not what you
want as you can see see the numbers that
we just went through look quite a bit
different and I bring this up to prove a
very important point just because a
language is in huge demand in the
industry if it's one of the harder
languages then you're more likely to
encounter frustration and give up there
is no point picking up a language that
is in high demand if you're never going
to complete it so it is better to turn
to that language once you have a robust
confidence in your understanding of the
fundamentals of programming in all
language languages now unlike human
languages the second language in
Computing is always much much easier
than your
first let me share with you my personal
story so that you understand why I've
come to this conclusion when I started I
didn't analyze it this way CU I did not
had the benefit of this course I decided
I wanted to build an Android app for
myself and not a toy app a serious app
eventually I gave up and had some
developers overseas build it for me and
even today it's still on the Android
play store
but I spent a little over four months
trying to build an Android app with zero
programming background except for a
little HTML now maybe all of you are
smarter than I was um that's entirely
likely but this was enormously
frustrating and a bad bad set of
decisions so I gave up it just felt
impossible and it kind of was it was
impossible given my level of knowledge I
knew nothing about the fundamentals of
programming forget about the Android
framework or Java I just knew nothing
about the fundamentals
and though I decided at that point in
time that I better get to know Java a
little bit I found it extremely hard
because I wanted to build an Android App
instead of understanding programming
through the language of java you see I
wanted to skip ahead skip the steps to
the end goal rather than going through
the steps and so it took me months and
months and months and months of getting
lost and discouraged and confused now
today I'm good at JavaScript and not bad
at Python and Java but notice that
they're all fairly big enough friendly
solid robust languages but I went about
it the hard way the long and roundabout
way a few weeks ago I happened to be
asked to build a very basic react native
prototype and I'd never done any react
native work before but because I've
invested so much in the fundamentals I
was actually able to understand the
basics of react native and knock
together a prototype in two days because
my fundamentals are strong that was not
possible for me a year and a half ago
it's taken a few years to get there so
what does this mean for you as a total
newa programming what should you do well
what would I do today I would recommend
that you pick a beginner friendly
language get very confident with its
core programming Concepts it may happen
that this beginner friendly language
takes you all the way to your goal
languages like JavaScript and python are
very popular for that reason because
sometimes they're all that you need to
know for what you want to achieve both
of these languages can now be used on
the front end and back end for example
that's full Stacks so most people can
accomplish 90% of their coding goals if
not the entire 100% of their goals with
just one language a second piece of
advice from my personal experience would
be to stay away from Frameworks and that
includes things like react and angular
and Android and the iOS Frameworks until
you feel your fundamentals are solid
it's better to be slow and get there
than to rush yourself and burn out and
never get there Frameworks are not the
same as languages they they require to
have a a fairly solid grasp of the
underlying fundamentals before you apply
the framework in my example using
Android before I understood Java was a
huge mistake React 2 needs a solid
understanding of JavaScript before you
can understand how to work with it same
thing with Jango and flask they require
an understanding of python these are
just examples of what Frameworks are and
the underlying languages first learn the
underlying Concepts via the language
before you move to Frameworks once you
understand a language then a framework
that's built in that language is
enormously easier and definitely less
frustrating to work with Okay but the
question that then arises is well Zubin
how do I know my fundamentals are solid
here's how I knew this is the best
answer I can give you and I think it's a
good one once you're able to read
documentation and tutorials fairly
fluently with enough speed that you're
automatically familiar with the concepts
you're reading without having to really
rack your brains to figure out what's
going on then you know you've got decent
fundamentals if you can read code in
other languages and have a decent idea
of what's going on then you're starting
to get the hang of the go Concepts and
it's probably a good indicator that
you're ready to keep moving to the next
level at that point as we always must
come back to your learning objectives
and goals at that point look at your
goals and ask yourself what is the next
learning objective and now you just keep
doing that keep repeating that process
until you achieve your end goal
each step will take you forward but
start small and start with things that
will give you that quick win that I keep
talking about keeps your confidence up
make sure it's measurable and frequently
measurable you know daily or weekly mini
goals and metrics and keep moving
onwards and upwards now if your goal in
the longer term is to find work as a
developer then be very specific about
the kind of work and also the kind of
employer that you're looking to join
because it's important to keep scanning
their job boods to identify the skills
that they keep recruiting for and then
that's your road map just develop those
skills later on in this section in the
next bunch of videos we will talk about
what it actually means to be a front end
Dev and a backend Dev and a full stack
Dev at various levels of depth but for
now just know that you can't be an
effective developer without
understanding common okay welcome back
in the last video we talked about a very
fundamental question around which type
of language you should try and start
with and how maybe that's the wrong
question in this video we're going to
start diving deeper into some of the
other fundamental questions and some of
the more practical aspects of starting
your journey to code in this video we
specifically going to talk about the
tools you need to learn to code now I'm
being very deliberate in my choice of
words I'm saying the tools you need to
learn to code that's not the same as the
tools you need to be an effective Ive
and efficient
programmer to learn the fundamentals of
programming you need to use only those
tools that contribute directly to making
learning easier and quicker most tools
in the development world will improve
your efficiency or your convenience
around coding but not that many are
actually necessary to learn to code and
that's a distinction I'm making in this
video so to learn to code let's start at
the first position which is what sort of
IDE should you use and IDE is the short
form for the integrated development
environment those are just fancy words
for a code editor you see technically
even the notepad or word software on
your laptop is a code editor because all
code is just text you can edit code and
you can write code in anything that
edits text coding is just writing text
but most people prefer to use software
specifically designed for programming
activity and there's a good reason for
that now these specifically chosen
programming environments or software
programs are more generally referred to
as
idees you also know that Microsoft Word
for example is better for texts and
paragraphs whereas Excel is better for
numbers though you can do either with
word or excel idees in the same vein are
better suited for programming than just
regular text editors they can be
configured and they are designed to give
you output and feedback within the
application they may also often have
useful features like debuggers Etc all
of which you will start to use down the
track once you've grown a bit as a
developer there are many many popular
IDs and you can really pick any one you
can pick atom or sublime or Visual
Studio code which are some of the more
popular free ones out there and then
there are paid ones like the ones that
you can get as a professional from a
company like say jet brains to learn
with though I would suggest you just go
with any one of the free or Community
Edition ones doesn't matter the
important thing is to just pick one of
the good popular ones and learn to use
it well which means you've got to pick
it and stick with it keyboard shortcuts
customizations configurations all these
little helpers come along only when you
stick to one application over a period
of time so sticking to one application
actually helps you get very good at
exploiting its features and getting
really familiar with them that's usually
why people are loyal to one over another
it's not because one is necessarily
hugely better than the other it's just
that switching to an unfamiliar one is a
huge loss of productivity when you
haven't got it set up properly and
setting up an IDE and configuring it to
your working style and preferences can
take a little bit of time again that's
not something you need to do right up
front you do that organically naturally
over a period of time as you learn to
code some idees are specifically needed
for the kind of work you intend to do
for example if you want to build an
Android app you're probably best off
trying to use Android studio and if you
want to build um iOS or Mac apps you're
best to use xcode now again we're
jumping a bit ahead of ourselves but
this is just to give you context as to
the different kind of ID environments
available if you're interested in data
science that's another example then
there are IDs like spider which are
designed specifically for that um but
you wouldn't want to use atomus Sublime
for that necessarily you can but a lot
of people would prefer not to because
spider is more fit for purpose also and
this is something that's relatively
recent as a development and fast
becoming my favorite go-to um
environment is online idees because
they're often integrated into your
training platform or you can just get
them free through a browser now if
you've ever been to free code camp for
example online which is a free coding
school um you would see that they
actually have an inbuilt IDE in the
browser for you to practice the same
thing goes for code academy and a bunch
of others another fantastic in browser
ID for quickly prototyping or practicing
or solving a simple functional problem
um which I personally use and love is
called
people.it that's repl.it now I should
say I'm not promoting it or you know I
don't get anything for this it's just
that I found it very very useful um
along with others like codepen which are
also extremely extremely useful many web
developers do use codepen and repl.it
and jsfiddle to do little Snippets in
practice these are typically referred to
as online playgrounds and they're very
good for prototyping small pieces and
sometimes even showcasing your work you
can actually build fairly sophisticated
applications with them but it's
generally not the way you'd end up going
because you have less control over how
your code's visible to the world now if
I didn't want to download an ID and I'm
just learning fundamentals I would
probably save myself a lot of the
initial setup friction and just use
something like a repel. it or code pin
or something for the first few weeks
anywhere and after that once I get
comfortable with that I may take out a
day or so to install a proper ID in my
laptop and set it up but that's just my
personal preference the important thing
like I said before is for you to pick
something that you find it easy to work
with and rewarding because it gives you
quick feedback and stick to it as you
will get more and more familiar and
Adept with it over time okay so let's
move on from IDs for just a moment
because a lot of people also get caught
up with things like Version Control
which is often popularly referred to as
git um and the other area people can
sometimes get stuck on is knowing how to
use terminal or Windows commands and
things like bash and terminal scripts
and shell
Etc now all of these skills and I'm not
going to go into too much detail because
these skills are very useful and
valuable for a programmer but they are
not necessary for a beginner to learn in
fact I would think that they can be a
little bit Arcane and sometimes tough to
comprehend and it's the kind of thing
that'll just overwhelm you for a
beginner don't worry about things like
version control for the first several
months don't worry about things like you
know writing things in the terminal in
these strange looking um boxes with lots
of text that make no sense forget about
all that don't let that distract you
just learn the fundamentals of
programming if you finding that you're
doing stuff in the terminal for example
and that you're lost all that means is
that you've jumped a few steps ahead so
you're using a resource that's probably
not designed for where you're at at your
level a well return return well-written
tutorial will always guide you through
using all the aspects that they're
talking about but often they presume
certain prior knowledge and if you don't
have that prior knowledge you're going
to feel overwhelmed okay so in this
section we've answered the question what
minimum tools do you need to learn to
code and I've tried to draw the
distinction between what you need to
learn and What You Need to Be an
Effective programmer to encourage you to
take it step by step and only focus on
those minimum tools you need to get
started with learning the fundamentals
programming
computers great I look forward to seeing
you in the next
video okay welcome back in the last
video we talked about the sort of tools
that you need to start learning the
fundamentals of programming rather than
tools you just need as a programmer in
this video let's talk about something a
little bit harder to grasp and perhaps a
lot more subtle but very practically
important to what you want to do and
that is how to identify and choose which
skills you need to acquire I want to
emphasize here I'm not talking about
what you want to have not what skills
you want to have but which skills you
need to have and that's only possible by
reference to the goals and plans
exercises which I'm sure you've done a
couple of times
now th that exercise should have helped
you identify what skills you need to
develop to meet your specific learning
objectives now we need to break those
broad goals down or those learning
objectives down into smaller discrete
subg goals Each of which have a clear
completion point that is a point when
you know you've achieved that subg goal
let's use examples of some popular goals
to help you understand what I mean by
choosing the right skills at a subgoal
level so a lot of people for example
want to be front-end developers or
backend Developers or full stack
Engineers front end means that they
handle the stuff that the end user sees
and interacts with back end means that
they handle the stuff that the user
doesn't directly interact with but which
is necessary for the front end to
deliver a certain user experience let's
take an example so you understand this
let's take an example like a blog site
the front end is where people can read
blogs and scroll through them and click
on them and write and edit them but when
they read write or edit things they're
actually consuming creating and
modifying data right I mean a Blog is
basically just data that data needs to
be saved somewhere it then needs to be
retrieved from that storage place and if
it's being edited it needs to be edited
and saved and record skied and so on so
the storage and retrieval is on the back
end of the application because that is
not what the user sees or interacts with
but what they see in the browser is the
front end if a full stack developer is
able to handle the coding for the front
end as well as the back end now if you
want to be a front end dev then don't
start learning about backend stuff
choose skills you need for front end
mainly skills like HTML CSS and
JavaScript as the programming language
for backend maybe you want to do it in
Java or python or even JavaScript for
full stack you'd need that and more like
learning about database design
Technologies even if you want to be a
full stack developer just start with
small goals start with the front end no
bit bit about that learn a bit of HTML
and CSS and then some JavaScript then
you can move on to things like node.js
for the back end and some other backend
language like PHP or python what my
point is here is that it's important to
learn to separate the advanced skills
from the beginner skills and that's
often hard to do because there are a
million different opinions people just
tell you oh this is what you want to do
this is what you need to know but you
need to separate them out into stages of
skill so a good way to do this
constructively is to speak to your
Mentor or others who've done what you're
planning to do people who walked down
this path before can give you a better
map a useful approach for yourself in
your Al time is to ask yourself is this
particular subgoal necessary for me to
learn next or is it just desirable this
is the want to versus need to question
is there something else that I need to
know more than this in other words
prioritize your skill acquisition in
accordance with what you need to do next
and there is always one thing not two or
more things that you need to do next
always boil it down to the one right
next thing your top priority can only be
one thing otherwise it's not your top
priority if it's shared with other
things that's the only way to be
effective when you're learning an
unhelpful question is should I know this
or will this make me a better coder
chances are the answer to both is yes in
order to achieve your long-term
objective but that's not going to help
answer the question of what's
immediately next as a
subgoal so that's what causes the
confusion and the decision making is so
hard it's because you ask a slightly
different question which gives you a
discard in answer when you focus on the
question of what comes next make sure
it's literally what comes next do I need
to know this next can I get to where I
want to be without knowing this is
another way of eliminating what doesn't
come next so sorry to hop on about this
but it's really really really important
to avoid the temptation to jump too far
ahead don't be stupid like me and and
try to go from zero to Android developer
in a week or a month you you know you
just cannot not get to the 10th floor of
a building without going up the stairs
or walking up the elevator whatever it
is unless of course you're Chuck
Norris step by step is my advice and
there is always one step that comes next
now you may be able to see three or four
steps don't try to do them all don't
leap them all just do the one steps it
does take a little work to figure out
what the next step is and you know You'
probably get it wrong the first few
times that's okay you're still building
your intuition around this so that's
also why I've designed these lessons for
you to keep coming back to because the
more you come back to them for quick
refresher the better you'll be at making
judgment calls like what's next the
whole point of this this class and this
course is to guide you through these
inevitable moments that come up time and
time again okay let's keep moving
because there are more videos to be done
welcome back in the last section we went
through a number of videos um where we
helped to work through the fundamental
decisions that anyone who's new to
programming needs to go through in order
to be effective in their Learning
Journey in this section we're going to
start looking at some of the strategies
what I call open Secrets um that make
people effective Learners now I've been
using dozens of learning strategies to
become what I would consider to be a
super learner over the last 15 plus
years and I've taught myself a number of
things and also learned professionally
through a number of of sources and I
know that you can actually boil down a
lot of the learning strategies for
coding specifically just a handful of
them and that's what I've done in this
section I've taken all the learning
strategies I know of experimented with a
whole bunch of them and reduce them to a
few so that you can use them in order to
identify which ones really work for you
as you learn to code um many of these
strategies aren't specific to coding but
I've tried to make them about coding so
that it's easier for you to
contextualize them and the reason I call
them open Secrets is because actually
everyone knows them is just that either
that they don't know they know them or
they're just not willing to apply them
but that's the secret that you've got to
apply so in this section we're going to
talk about some ways to learn new skills
very fast as fast as possible really
while growing your coomet so it's not
just about learning things very quickly
and then not being competent in them
it's really important that you retain
competence um in terms of the sources
for a lot of these strategies I've
picked them up from the education
Sciences from my study of psychology and
meta learning um and even the experience
of other super Learners like Tim Ferris
Etc been really useful to validate some
of the strategies look I'm really
excited about this section so let's not
waste any more time and let's Jump Right
In I'll see you in the next
video now very quick update for me in
2023 at the end of 2023 um this used to
be true that I'd learn most on videos
but it's actually no longer true on the
job for me anymore because as I get more
senen and experienced um a lot of the
prerequisite knowledge is already in my
possession in in circumstances where I'm
working with things I'm somewhat
familiar and have the right intuition
and so it's actually much easier for me
to Now understand what the doc documents
mean what written resources are trying
to tell me I'm able to pass through that
information much quicker simply because
I'm a bit more experienced compared to
you know four or five years ago however
there are still some topics um
especially brand new topics are just
topics that I'm trying to learn entirely
for fun of my own growth where I
typically still will start with videos
because personally I find videos the
most efficient way it's there's a lot of
words that you don't have to deal with
when you can just watch somebody do it
right visual media much more Rich so I
still use it but on the job I find more
often than not I'll do a very quick
Google search a stack Overflow search a
chat GPD search whatever it is find the
text reason about it go to the documents
find my way through the documents and
it's actually much faster than trying to
find which video is the right one for me
because sometimes videos can be hours
long right so it's actually much more
efficient this way so you will notice
too as you get better and more ad dep
and more familiar with things um your
the your chosen medium for finding the
solution that you need in that moment
will change depending on what how much
time you have what your goals are what
your objectives are and what your
favorite method of learning is okay in
the last video we covered the first Open
Secret which we call the minimum
effective dose in this video we're going
to talk about a big and very important
secret secret number two now you do
remember from the introduction to this
section that I did caveat that these
secrets aren't really Secrets at all I
mean they're open Secrets so I want you
to remember that um and I'm calling
these a secret because everyone wants to
know what the special source is in the
recipe for success but they already know
what it is and yet they think it's
something else in fact you probably
already guessed what secret number two
is because everyone knows actually what
it is and sadly it's not
glamorous the secret secret number two
is is
practice that's it hey I did warn you
that it wasn't going to blow your mind
but you know practice is so completely
underrated and maybe it would blow all
our minds if we just saw how much
practice goes into excellence and what
what incredible things you can achieve
by just following this secret I don't
know that's just what I believe but I'll
tell you what let's dig into it hey did
you guys know that Benjamin Franklin
used to study his favorite authors this
was back when Ben Franklin was training
himself to be an author he would study
his favorite authors and I don't mean
just study his authors he would actually
pour over their books and writings then
put them away and for days on end try
and reproduce those writings himself by
trying to imitate imitate the bits of
them he really liked that's an enormous
amount of work I mean Benjamin Franklin
effectively practiced being the authors
that he admired that is an enormous
amount of commitment
the reason why I think this is still a
secret this practice concept is because
all of us have a natural tendency to
want to avoid the one thing that works
which is practice the secret is that it
is actually guaranteed to work practice
will 100% get you to the level you want
it may take you more or less time than
someone else that's almost irrelevant to
be honest and maybe it'll take you more
effort or a little bit less effort
really depends on what your inherent
skills are but you can't avoid the fact
that practice is the only thing
guaranteed to get you the results okay
enough preaching about the big secret
the real question for you to make this
practical is what are the effective
forms of practice when it comes to
learning to code because that's what
this course is all about so I will share
with you through my extended period of
experimentation and trial and error the
principles I've learned about effective
practice ice when it comes to
programming number one programming
requires different skills to come
together and it's important to keep in
mind that each of those skills need
practice so two is about getting more
specific you're learning fundamental
programming Concepts we talked about
this in the fundamental decision section
you're learning how to program a
computer for this you need to practice
things like syntax of your chosen
language and the way in which you
structure a small code statement how you
declare a variable how you may need to
keep in mind what sort of data is
represented by that variable and all
these little things all these little
things matter and they get better they
become more natural for you with
practice you know what the famous joke
about coding is how a semic semicolon
can crash a code it's true so even
putting in semicolons in the right place
where the language requires it does
matter the more you do the more fluid
you become it becomes like a second
language the more fluent you become in
writing those basic statements but
initially it takes time so you you need
to practice with patience the third
principle I can share with you is that
as you practice more and more complex
chunks of code say for example you're
asking a user for a little input maybe
their age and then you want to add 10 to
that age and tell them that in in 10
years they're going to be X years old
right a plus 10 now that requires
practicing slightly more complex levels
than just the initial stages it's basic
conditional logic it's okay if you're
this many years now in 10 years you will
be doing you will be this many years
which means you're X plus 10 years which
is a mathematical operation but there's
also an if statement there so to do
these patterns of code which are
absolutely the building blocks of a
program you have to learn the Habit it's
it it'll feel strange at first and it
takes time so these patterns and
routines take practice so you start off
with the basics then you move into these
small little code patterns and chunks
and that'll then take practice even
though the easier bits now start to feel
like second nature all right the next
principle is as you're building up in
complexity you'll need to really start
to practice how to Google the right
questions to get the right answers now
people may not appreciate this but about
90% of the time you spend writing code
is actually spend researching the best
way to do it um that could be the most
efficient way to do it or the correct
answer for something you're not really
sure how to do so make Google your
friend it's one of the best friends a
developer can have and Googling the
right thing is very important so that
you get the answer as soon as you can
initially I didn't even know what was
going wrong so my Google searches did
take me to the answer now I have
developed a really good intuition I can
see what's going on I can see the error
and I can in my head calculate okay it
looks like this is what's going wrong I
just don't know how to fix it quite yet
and so I can go in and Google it's a
huge part of a coder's workflow make no
mistake Googling is a massive part of
what you do as a coder So reading
through resources like stack Overflow or
Wikipedia or the documentation takes
practice too and that gets better the
more you understand how the language is
working or the framework is working the
more you understand what you're doing
then when you read the advice you get it
all just makes sense almost effortlessly
over time
so you may ask for sauce but if you know
specifically you want Tobasco that helps
a lot right that's that's an example I
can give you of how Googling
specifically will give you a much better
response than just asking for sauce okay
so that covers some of the big
principles and you can see there's a
chronology to it each Builds on the
complexity that went before it now let
me show show you these skills take time
and practice and I'm I've hopped on on
this also in the course that it's not
something you can do in a month or two
or three
well maybe you can but I wouldn't expect
that initially when you try to read
documentation it's going to overwhelm
you and probably throw up many more
questions than than the answers um
that's okay that's actually a signal
that you may have jumped ahead so step
back a bit go back a few steps to the
level that feels right for you and
slowly work up from there an example I
can give you of this principle is when I
was younger I taught myself how to play
the guitar today I'm pretty good at it
but when I first started first I to
learn how to press the strings right to
the guitar and then if the guitar Was
Out Of Tune I had to actually learn how
to tune the guitar so that playing it
actually made sense so it was so painful
it hurt my fingers and you know I think
oh I'm going to try and learn this tune
today but it would take me one week to
learn it and not just a few hours
because there was so much that I had to
learn to even get to a point where I
could play a tune it's the same
principle with coding it it just seems
to take forever at first but that
flywheel just keeps turning faster and
faster the more you practice it so
practice practice practice be patient
practice practice practice I know I've
said practice a lot of times this video
because I want to drive the point home I
would recap this section but I think
I've made the point abundantly clear
you'll never know whether there's enough
practice but you will know whether
you're being fluid and if you're not
fluid then you could use a little more
practice that's the rule of thumb I go
by all right so don't skip the step but
let's move ahead to see secret number
three okay welcome back in the last
video I revealed to you the Earth
shattering jawdropping
lifechanging Cosmos quaking secret of
practice in this video I'm going to
share with you something maybe a little
bit more down to earth we're going to
call it secret number three and the
secret really is that you don't need to
learn only from experts or from people
online you can learn from your peers and
others who are at a similar stage or
maybe even who are slightly behind you
and so I call this secret to is greater
than one because really what it's saying
is you don't have to do it alone and
doing it with somebody else can take
many forms which we'll talk about
shortly but doing it with other people
is a very good way to embed the
knowledge in your head but it's not
something you want to do too early in
your journey so my personal suggestion
is maybe don't do it in your first 4 to
8 weeks just concentrate on yourself and
building your first layer of
fundamentals and then after that initial
phase start to involve one or two other
people in your journey to code now when
I say involve others there are three
ways that I would recommend you do this
you don't have to do all of them or you
can do all of them or choose the ones
that work and are convenient for you
okay so the three ways I would recommend
you do this are number one read the code
of others from tutorials or even just
give GitHub it's great but try and read
the code of others especially on GitHub
um over time you learn a lot maybe not
initially it'll feel like a real
struggle but as your knowledge grows
your ability to read other people's code
and know what's going on will improve
and so that will teach you not just how
to do things but also how not to do
things you'll learn either they've done
something better or they've done
something that doesn't work as well as
something you worked at all great
learning some of the needest tricks I
learn learn was from Reading other
people's code thanks to the open source
movement right so get involved with the
open source movement if you like if if
you feel comfortable and you don't have
to intimidate Yourself by thinking you
need to build an entire app on your own
that's not what open source necessarily
means you can start really small by just
offering to write their documentation a
little better which is often an
overlooked part people are so busy
focusing on the code that they don't
write great documentation or the
documentation is not beginner friendly
as a beginner you know how to make it
beginner friendly so that's how you can
get started by contributing reading
other people's code is actually really
valuable when you need to use libraries
and chunks of other people's code or in
a professional environment where you
probably get a job in a place where
you're not writing something from
scratch right you'll have to work with
other people's code so getting the hang
of reading code is really important in a
professional environment okay number two
another way to make it a little more
collaborative or social um and involve
others is to teach what you're learning
a lot of people have done an incredible
job writing little tutorials or blog
posts telling others how to do something
but the reason they're writing it is
because they've just leared or they're
in the process of learning how to do
that even I did that um I maintained a
small and and not periodically updated
it was fairly infrequently updated blog
um but summarizing the key principles
that I had learned part of it was to
document for myself so that I could
always come back and have a quick
reference guide to building something or
a piece of you know or a functionality
but also as a way to force myself to
bring these Concepts into words that are
comprehensible to other people which
then builds your ability to communicate
technical things that's a really really
important skill right the ability to
communicate your technical Concepts to
translate them from your idea in your
head to something another coder can
understand is a vital skill especially
at the workplace if you want to be a
professional dip if someone asks you a
really great question and you don't
suddenly know the answer to that that's
a really good sign that hey you know
your learning could could get even
better in that subject so you you just
tend to learn by teaching the
opportunities to teach others are
actually more common than you think you
can teach people at work you can teach
people at Community programs you know
you can write like I said essays blogs
and contributing to open source there's
actually a lot of ways in which you can
teach others and help share the
knowledge technique or method number
three is pair programming which
is quite common in the development World
especially in the educational scene but
also as part of training given at work
um where you know developer teams are
encouraged to PIR program and this is
because it really really does work the
concept is you and someone else will
take turns at programming one person is
the driver which basically means that
they're going to be actually typing out
the code and you know writing it out
into the IDE and the other person's the
Navigator who's the person who's doing
the thinking and trying to articulate
their thinking in language that that the
driver can understand and type into the
IDE so the effect of this is that it
teaches you to communicate technical
Concepts while collaborating with others
and developing the empathy to know know
how to express an idea that's in your
head in a clear concise way that
somebody else sitting next to you can
immediately implement it now you do
switch quite often so you know you may
do 15 minutes 20 minutes as the driver
and then take over as the Navigator and
you switch back and forth um and if you
can do this it's a really valuable skill
at the workplace sometimes maybe your
Mentor or your model if you happen to
know them or have access to them um Can
can do this with you and train you up so
if you do it with someone who's a lot
better than you there's a great deal of
learning but even if you do it with
someone your level or slightly behind
you that's fine too you don't need to do
it in physical proximity with each other
so in this modern day and age we can do
this online you can use Hangouts or
Skype or whatever it is and a screen
share and write code in real time with
each other and collaborate that way all
of these three techniques are really
really really helpful at bedding down
the knowledge that you've developed um
as some of you may know repeating what
you've learned with a bit of spacing in
between is a highly effective technique
of making sure you remember longer and
one great way of repeating it is by
having to teach someone else okay so
that's secret number three which is two
is greater than one and I will now see
you in the next video okay welcome back
in the last video we talked about secret
number three which is how two is greater
than one in this video I'd like to talk
to you about the reality of coding which
really is quite intellectually
demanding and along with being
intellectually demanding it's also quite
emotionally demanding and can be quite
draining and the reason for that is you
spend a lot of your time especially in
the initial part of your journey you're
going to spend a lot of your time being
confused and frustrated uh dealing with
a lot of setbacks um and that can be
quite hard so secret number four which
we're going to talk about in this video
is going to be quick it's sounds trivial
but it's really really important because
it does set you up for Success the only
thing is it's kind of hard to remember
to do it when you're in the thick of
coding so secret number four is called
pace yourself and it's really
important when I say pace yourself I
really mean two things
one I recommend you follow a process
where you learn something in a finite
amount of time that's not too long and
then you take a short break for
something else then return
I do not recommend that you do marathon
sessions even though that's what it
looks like is normal in shows like
Silicon Valley and stuff I personally
follow the pomodora technique which is a
proven way to keep your learning
resilience and redention up I can add
more links for you in the in the in the
notes to this
lesson second thing I'd recommend you do
do when it comes to pacing yourself is
to learn when to walk away now this
sounds really quite silly but it's
actually really important getting stuck
when you're coding is a very normal and
sadly very common and inevitable part of
coding coding is just one of those
things that can consume your focus
completely but the problem with that is
that our Focus gets narrower over time
and so does our ability to think
laterally and creatively solve problems
over a single session that extends for
too long you will find your cognitive
capacities is declining so when we don't
solve our problems we'll get frustrated
we then feel angry and we want to give
up and we want to avoid a situation that
discourages us that much right so rather
than exhausting ourselves over long
sessions I recommend getting up quite
frequently doing a little exercise
walking the dog meditating listening to
some music that improves your State uh
you know do things that switch your
emotional and mental state and these are
all proven techniques to re resetting
yourself mentally now I should warn you
that when you're in the thck of coding
or you feel you're on the verge of a
breakthrough or you're really stuck and
it's really annoying you that you're
stuck it'll really feel like you cannot
possibly step away from that problem at
that moment you're you're going to feel
like that's the worst time to walk away
it's so hard to do when you're deep in
code I I accept that I recognize that I
struggle with this pretty much every day
really but I have found out almost
universally that when you walk away from
the problem especially when you're
coding somehow it gets solved
subconsciously and when you return back
to the problem you tend to solve it much
faster or you attack it from a new angle
that only could have occurred to you
when you release the problem for a while
I've made the opposite mistake on
several occasions right I made the
mistake of breaking my own rules and
coding for 4 hours straight or something
and then getting massively stuck in the
second hour and then I lost the other
other two hours because I just
stubbornly refused to step back and give
it some breathing room and then I come
back later on and the solution actually
took me 10 minutes so I recognize the
concentration very hard to break but
concentrating for a long time with great
discipline on the wrong thing doesn't
mean you're going to find the right
solution so take a break have a kit kat
do something completely different and
come back just as a completely
interesting side note and this is not so
much of educational value here but there
is a phenomenon that you should watch
out for when you code very intensely
what happens is you you can tend to
start dreaming of code and it can
actually impact your sleep now I
personally have gone through this
several times I still go through it when
I code too late into the night and then
go straight to bed and after a few days
of this I'm pretty useless it's just
that your brain hasn't shut down
properly if you're curious about this
this phenomenon is sometimes called the
tetris effect and I've added some links
in the notes to this lesson as well so
just keep in mind to recap that mental
tiredness is a very normal part of
really getting into code coding is very
addictive and Incredibly absorb loing
and that's what's fun about it that's
what's so rewarding about it but that's
also what's so exhausting about it and
so it makes it doubly important that to
sustain yourself you need to pace
yourself and that's what the secret
number four is pace yourself so you can
be resilient and bounce back keeping
these things in mind will make you much
more effective in managing yourself on
your journey and we know that better
self-management means you'll achieve
more goals which means you'll be more
successful all right that's it I will
see you in the conclusion to the section
now all right guys congratulations
you've reached the end of yet another
section and you are making such great
progress you're going at such a great
Pace that you're going to be done very
very soon in the last section we talked
about the open Secrets as I call them
that um help you learn to code very
effectively and so now I think you're
ready to actually go into the next
section which is going to cover some of
the setbacks that many people do
encounter I hope you don't but it's very
possible that you will and I hope to
take you through some techniques that I
found incredibly effective at dealing
with those with those setbacks
constructively and effectively so you
should be really proud with with the
progress you're making with every
passing video you're getting so much
closer to your goals um and I hope
you're feeling good about that so take a
short break and I'll see you in the next
video Welcome Back to the next section
now all the videos in this section are
designed to help you prepare mentally we
going to make sure that you have a
really really solid unbeatable
mindset why is mindset so important it's
because the quality of your thinking
when confronted with certain problems is
what's going to help you see your way
through those problems of your hard
times and by definition hard times are
really hard because setbacks and
failures and doubt are really difficult
things to deal with the coding journey
is filled with these setbacks and it's
filled with these negative experiences
so it's very very easy to quit it's hard
to persist and very easy to quit but how
you think about it your mindset is going
to be the difference between persisting
and quitting and that is the difference
between achieving your goals and failing
because failure only really happens when
you stop trying or when you quit and as
you know now my goal and the goal for
you in this in this entire course is to
do everything we can can to make sure
that you don't get discouraged or let
the failures cause you to quit we need
to make sure that you don't give up so
that you achieve your goal of becoming a
coda if you were an athlete for example
mental conditioning would just be as
important as the physical conditioning
you would be trained to handle your
emotions when you're playing what seems
to be a game without any hope if you
look at Champions in the sporting world
they're usually someone who overcomes
the ODS and fights the battle when it
seems hard to win winning easy games is
is not the mark of a champion fighting
back the setbacks with a great attitude
is what makes the champion we see this
all the time in the sporting world so
why shouldn't it be the same for coding
I firmly believe that if we train for
our learning objectives like we would
train for a sport we would get fantastic
results instead of a physical Marathon
just think of this as training for an
intellectual one there no real
difference this intellectual marathon is
also filled with setback and confusion
and doubt and failure and there are
certain common themes that have emerged
from my experience and my research into
how people experience their Journeys to
learn to code this section takes those
most common themes and trains you to
recognize them to see them for what they
are to deal with them and not be tripped
up by them so you've made it this far
which means you've got what it takes to
be a Champion for this intellectual
Marathon so let's keep going and I'll
see you in the next lecture all right
one of the first setbacks I think anyone
who's learning to code is going to
encounter is that sense of complete and
utter confusion things just don't seem
to make sense initially right there are
all sorts of competing words and
inconsistent terminology Concepts that
you're reading about even at at a
beginner level that just do not make Mak
sense you cannot understand them you
don't know exactly what they're trying
to say and your brain really feels
overloaded by the information because
you're not just reading trying to read
and understand each word in that has a
specific meaning and so your brain is
really working hard to fully absorb the
meaning of every word or every sentence
while at the same time trying to stick
to the overall concept that's being
communicated you are definitely not
alone the problem is not many people
talk about this which is why I'm doing
this video so the sense of total and
utter confusion is normal and possibly
even inevitable often and this is where
I want you to really think about it
often it's also a signal it could be a
signal for example that maybe you've
skipped a step
somewhere and maybe it's not always the
wrong thing skipping a step is only the
wrong thing if it wastes your time
energy and money or or if it frustrates
you so much that you feel like quitting
or are discouraged from
continuing so if you're feeling confused
the first thing to ask yourself is why
am I in this
position why am I doing something that
is confusing me so much what's the
reason for this confusion could it be
that the resource is not right for me
could it be that I've have jumped too
far
ahead the second reason is much more
likely if you're feeling discouraged and
frustrated it's usually reason number
two because reason number one just makes
you go find a better resource once you
are confident and have strong
fundamentals reason one stops being a
reason it actually stops causing
frustration or fear or at least happens
much less often with experience you
learn to recognize reason one so well
that you immediately correct your course
of action but initially reason number
two which is that you've jumped too far
ahead can cause all sorts of doubts and
emotional reactions and that's why it's
such a dangerous setback for many
people so the best way to tackle this is
to assume that you've driven into some
sort of dead end some dead end alley so
reverse your car back up and go back to
the last resource that you were really
comfortable with that is the last
learning that you felt you had
mastered it should be the learning
objective immediately before this dead
end that you've gone
down then once you get there ask
yourself what is a smaller Next Step
than the one that I previously took that
got me all
confused if you look carefully you will
see a smaller step that'll get you there
typically the confusion happens when you
try and jump over three steps at a time
rather than just the one next best step
and really that's all you need to do now
it may sound frustrating that you have
to do that and you may think it's going
to take you more time but I promise you
taking a smaller step and not getting
stuck is much faster than trying to LEAP
prematurely to a bigger step and falling
down a hole it's important to build up
slowly into the lesson that got you
confused so much now I totally respect
and understand that we're all impatient
but if you're in a hurry to get
someplace the quickest route is always
the one you know you can navigate rather
than the random experimental route that
looks shorter but you have no idea what
it's all about for now let's recap
quickly being confused and lost is
common and it's simply a signal that
you've jumped a little bit too far ahead
assume that you could have gotten to
this point by taking slightly smaller
steps so go back and give yourself
smaller quicker wins it may take you a
little more time but in the long run it
takes a lot less time when you don't get
stuck and confused okay I'll see you in
the next section okay welcome back in
the last video we talked about one of
the most common setbacks which is the
feeling of absolute and utter confusion
in this video we're going to talk about
something related and just as common but
very very different at the same time
it's the sense of being completely
overwhelmed now it's important to
distinguish the two types of feeling
overwhelmed
one is when you're overwhelmed because
there's just too much information it's
like drinking from a fire hose this
you're just taking on too much
information that's one type the second
type happens quite often when you start
to learn something you start to learn to
code for example and you realize as you
go along just how much you don't know
and how much there is to know and
suddenly you realize that to achieve
your learning goals and objectives it's
going to take a lot more learning than
you had originally planned and that can
feel very very overwhelming so that's
the second type of overwhelm and I refer
to that as an estimation error you've
not estimated correctly how much you're
going to have to learn to achieve the
goal and the plan you've set out for
yourself so two types for these two
types typically there are three reasons
a total of three reasons that could
explain one or both of these types of
overwhelm so we're going to talk about
the types and the reasons for feeling
those types of of overwhelm in this
video so feeling overwhelmed comes from
three reasons as I've mentioned one is
you've skipped steps and jumped ahead
two you've not quite had a specific
enough Focus resulting in you doing far
too much and three you've underestimated
the size of the goals
specifically how much you're going to
have to learn in order to achieve your
goal now we've covered the first one
that is skipping ahead and having jumped
too far ahead in the previous video and
confusion and the solution and my
recommendations are the same so I'm not
going to cover that again here just
return to that video anytime you need to
remind yourself let's look at reason
number two what happens when you're
feeling overwhelmed from having to
absorb way too much information what
could the reason for that be well that
feeling is a signal that you're
absorbing way more information than you
can process which typically Happ happens
because you're trying to do too much so
the solution is to ask yourself why do I
feel like this and then write down all
the pieces that you're simultaneously
attacking all the things that you're
simultaneously doing that's making you
feel this way and really ask yourself
honestly why they need to be done
simultaneously why do I need to do all
these things at the same time do they
really need to be done at the same time
so instead of having them as a giant big
list of things to do just rewrite them
as a sequence of steps and make sure and
I cannot emphasize this enough but make
sure that each step in that sequence is
the minimum effective dose for the next
step and that all these steps taken
together are each 100% necessary not
nice to have but 100% necessary to
achieve your learning objectives in some
senses each step that you're looking at
here is the learning objective of the
previous step and it telescopes upwards
that way so follow this recipe and break
it down now I've said this before and
I'm going to say it again yes this
approach may make you feel like you're
extending your time to completion it's
going to take you longer to get there
and that really can feel disappointing
and stressful and frustrating I
completely empathize but also let me
promise you that that is just an
appearance it's going to feel that way
but it's not actually going to be that
way it is going to perhaps take you
longer in the short term over the next
few days but it's saves you a lot of
time in the long term because you're not
going to get stuck that often and you're
certainly not going to be so discouraged
that you just throw your hands up in the
air and say I'm not doing this and then
you lose a few months so please please
trust me on this until you see it
working for yourself follow these
suggestions do less which is doing more
and be absolutely clear that each step
needs to feed into the very next step
after it so the mindset that you need to
have as you go through this process in
this training is that feeling
overwhelmed is really quite natural and
a very normal part of the learning
process especially when you're extending
outside your comfort zone which is
always a good good thing so the mindset
and the feeling of overwhelm how you
relate the two is by recognizing that
that feeling of overwhelm is a valuable
signal not something to be afraid of but
a good piece of information
and it's teaching you to manage yourself
and to plan better if you feel like
quitting that's normal too just remember
that this new mindset you have is meant
to prevent you from quitting so instead
of giving up in your goal just change
your approach to one that's better
suited to achieving your goal which is
what this entire video is all about now
let's talk very briefly about question
number three or rather reason number
three if you're feeling overwhelmed
because you've suddenly realized that
you underestimated how much work you're
going to have to do how much there is to
learn then the main question you need to
ask yourself is do you still want to
achieve this goal so you end up really
having to revisit your goals and plans
and say do I really still want this am I
still committed to achieving this look
hard at your plans and goals from
section one and if the answer is yes
then adjust your learning goals from
section one to reflect the additional
steps it's going to take you've got
enough learning and training now to know
how to redesign your plan and do it in a
way that's
sustainable however if you decide you
don't really want to continue to learn
to code then that is your choice but if
you're thinking this I would encourage
you to not take that decision to not
proceed because you're feeling
intimidated if you decide not to proceed
don't let it be because you're giving up
but because you have other better
priorities for your time okay so let's
recap the typical reasons why why coding
is overwhelming falls into two types or
categories one is just the share
information overload and the second is
the realization that you've
underestimated how much learning is
required for your specific goals both
are solvable problems because both are
just signals and they're common they're
normal and they can be dealt with very
effectively using the tips and
techniques I've suggested in this video
okay let's move to the next video okay
welcome back in the last video we
learned to accept that feeling over
welmed is a normal and natural signal
and can be a useful signal that actually
helps us improve our plan so that we can
achieve our learning objectives in a
better way in this video we are going to
talk about something that affects every
single person on Earth doubt
specifically self-doubt we all doubt
ourselves and no matter what we see the
truth is everyone is out there doubting
themselves fairly
constantly we are all much better at
looking confident than feeling confident
and that's also true of coders there is
a term for this among super high
Achievers many of them report
experiencing what is known as imposter
syndrome which is the feeling that they
don't really deserve their success and
they may be caught out anytime now for
being
frauds so why am I telling you all this
if big Achievers in all walk of Life
feel doubt and even feel like they may
be frauds then feeling doubt when you're
learning a new and difficult skill is
totally okay that's a normal healthy
time it's fine you're okay it may feel
like you're not fast enough or not
talented enough to learn to code but
you're wrong it just feels that way this
is a great time to ask your Mentor or
model on whether they felt it and how
they dealt with with it I guarantee they
felt it and have struggled with it I did
too and all my mentors did too a lot
I've included the first blog I ever
wrote about this as a resource to this
video If you read some other resources
in this course you would have seen this
is a recurring theme this theme of Doubt
there is no great trick to beating self
doubt it boils down to two fairly
mechanical things one except this is
normal Universal and perfectly okay it's
an important mindset to have then choose
deliberately to ignore it your doubts
and fears are only the voices in your
head they are not actual facts the fact
is that you cannot do this task in front
of you yet remember one of the resources
I referred to earlier Carol Dre's book
called mindset in that book she talks
about how people sometimes think that
they cannot do something whereas the
better way of thinking of it the more
productive and accurate way of thinking
of it is that you cannot do this right
now thinking that you can never do it is
an opinion thinking that you can't do it
right now is a fact and it implies you
can do it soon having that mindset is a
growth mindset and it helps to remind
yourself that everything is learnable it
just takes time and effort the second
mechanical step that will be part of
your mindset going forward is to Simply
keep at it that's it there's no magic
just keep at it we've talked about
practice revisit that section maybe read
a little bit more Let it take a little
bit more time it takes the time it takes
but setbacks to your time plans are
something I cover in the next video so
we'll wait for that for now just
remember that if you can't do it that is
just one snapshot in time for this
moment you cannot do it you will
eventually be able to do it just like at
first you probably sucked at Dy driving
or at writing and now you can hold a
heated debate with someone while driving
and you can answer phone calls while
writing it will come to you don't worry
just keep moving forward heck it's not
even my advice it's advice from nobody
is going to hit as hard as life but it
ain't about how hard you hit it's about
how hard you can get hit and keep moving
forward how much you can take and keep
moving forward that's how wi it is done
so when you're feeling doubt don't
assume that this is a signal that you're
not good enough doubt is not really a
signal it's a human condition thing it
is our inner dialogue and it's usually
an opinion not a fact just focus on the
facts you're going to learn to code
that's a fact okay enough motivational
speaking I will see you in the next
video Welcome Back in the last video we
talked about self-doubt and some of the
mindsets you need to have to effectively
tackle it how common it is how Universal
it is and how it's not really that much
of a problem to deal with if you know
how similarly in this video we're going
to talk about the frustration that comes
from coding taking the kind of time it
does unfortunately it does take more
time than you expect and that's almost
universally the case in one of the
previous videos on myths we talked about
one of the myths being that this is
something that you can do really quickly
for example you may be tempted to
believe that you can knock together your
next startup in your garage or your dor
room in a weekend the popular myth
around this is unfortunately not true so
the question then is what is the mindset
that you need to deal with the
inevitable time it's going to take and
let me say this again progress is going
to be slower than you hoped that is
almost always the way it is it's just a
fact so knowing that what sort of
mindset do you need to make sure that
you're not going to give up that's what
we're going to answer in this video so
knowing that it's a fact that it's going
to take more time than you expect or
plan doesn't really make it much easier
to accept does it but it is worth
remembering that what we're now dealing
with is not really learning anymore what
we need to do is develop a mindset about
patience specifically the patience to
work until we achieve our goal now this
may sound like the most common sense
stuff to you like why are you telling me
this Zubin I know all this yes you do
everybody does and yet almost everybody
experiences the frustration it's because
there is a gap between what we know and
what we believe about ourselves in a
situation so what's really important is
to cultivate in yourself the mindset of
patience and discipline and it's not
just about coding the reason we know
this Open Secret and the reason we all
are aware of this mindset in theory is
because it works in every area of life
and in fact I'd argue it's particularly
relevant in coding for someone who's new
to the journey of learning how to code I
would actually encourage you to view it
as a form of training see programming as
a craft because that's really what it is
you have to have a Craftsman's mindset
you need to Apprentice yourself and all
crafts take time to master it's a slow
deliberate and steady process and
through it you will also learn to
appreciate that estimating coding tasks
is actually hard you'll learn to do it
much much better with practice no doubt
but it'll give you a newfound empathy
for the idea that you can knock together
something very quickly in a few hours
the reason why this mindset of patience
and discipline is critical is because
there is a real danger that you will run
out of patience and give up and we don't
want that right sometimes in some
circumstances it is okay to decide not
to do it for example where you're in an
entrepreneur and you run out a Runway
and you only needed to code for the sake
of building a certain product so maybe
you ran out of Runway maybe you found a
technical co-founder maybe you found a
prototyping tool online that's a more
efficient path to achieving your goal in
that case it sort of makes sense to not
code if the coding was only a means to
that end but if you intend to learn to
code because you want to be a coder then
losing patience is dangerous because it
will cause you to take shortcuts and
waste more time and effort or it'll
cause you to give up in which case
you'll never become a coder so here are
some ways for you to overcome the
discouragement of slow progress one go
back to the section on goals and plans
and the five ws and refresh yourself on
why you want to code why did you want to
learn to code in the first place and is
that reason something that still
resonates do you still really really
want it when you really want something
and the reason why you want something is
still very fresh in your mind you will
not give up that's just how the human
mind works number two remind yourself of
the simple but inconvenient math of
learning something new success is equal
to time plus effort there's no getting
around it but it also means that taking
longer means more success because it's
linked to time you know I personally
struggled with this situation and this
mindset so many times I mean progress
for me was so slow I ran out of Runway I
ran out of patience and then I ran out
of confidence at one time I had more
money than I had time at another time I
had more time than I had money and each
time I adjusted my plan to suit my
specific circumstances that's actually
how I discovered the concept of the
minimum effective dose to get the
outcome I considered adequate given my
limited resources and then I guess my
life changed a little bit when I read a
certain letter that Tim Ferris included
in his book tools of Titans I've
provided a link in the resources section
to this video this letter summarized the
whole issue of slow progress brilliantly
It's a letter from a coach to Tim Ferris
and I've included an except of this
letter in the course resources but you
know what I recommend getting the book
it's worth it even just for that one
letter definitely read it in fact the
first word of that letter sums up the
mindset you need I'm not going to tell
you what it is cuz you've got to go and
find it yourself okay that's enough for
now I'll see you in the next video hey
welcome back in the last video we talked
about how slow progress can be we saw
that slow progress is an inevitable part
of learning complex skills initially it
takes ages we seem completely
incompetent in fact there is a
well-known framework for understanding
the stages that every human being has
has to go through as they travel from
being a newb to being a master here it
is and unfortunately I don't have a
source for the drawing other than the
Reddit link I found it at it's a
fantastic drawing and it sums it up
beautifully I've added the Reddit Link
in the resources section to this video
as you can see moving from step two to
step three is the hardest it's really
hard and it's that truff of Despair that
overcomes a lot of people
so in this video we're going to talk
about getting stuck
why because that happens a lot in coding
and you need the right strategies and
mentality around it let me assure you
this happens to senior experience
programmers too I've added another
resource to this video which is a quora
post on getting stuck in programming
just for example sake it's normal and
common it happens at all levels you just
get get better at dealing with it mainly
through better strategies that come from
your
experience personally the first few
months I got stuck a lot I mean let's be
honest console errors look like a mess
they are absolutely bizarre looking and
are definitely not beginner friendly
it's just this crazy jumble of text and
weird words and numbers it makes no
sense and debugging really does feel
frustrating and mysterious so I got
stuck and stuck and stuck and stuck it
made me so angry because often I was
following somebody else's tutorials and
then things a change in some library or
package or the the operating system or
something and so the tutorial is no
longer up to date and people are writing
new tutorials but I'm stuck in the old
one don't know about the new one and so
my projects pretty much wasted or at
least it feels like that to me so my
suggestion is this when when an error
happens the first thing to tell yourself
is okay this is now going to take me
some time accept it I don't know how
much time so best not to be in a hurry I
guess maybe better not to expect to
resolve it today it would be great if I
could but it's very possible this may
take a few days next ask yourself can I
make any sense of this error message
look for any clue that you can Google
about and then you Google the errors and
keep searching till you find someone
that has handled something similar so
sometimes it could be a small error or
bug in your code and you need to step
away and then you'll see it the point is
you step away and then you slowly build
up the skill of troubleshooting your
errors and Google and stack Overflow are
your friends but it does take a lot of
patience and effort to read through all
the results carefully and to understand
where this error is coming from that
also takes
experience sometimes people use terms
and words interchangeably and that can
cause a lot of confusion for you so just
just keep patient this is part of the
learning process and remember pace
yourself we've talked about this pace
yourself so you can be sustainable
unfortunately as we talked about in the
last video it's going to take the time
it takes and as you experience these
sort of frustrations and getting stuck
more often you do get faster at
diagnosing and resolving the issues but
if you rush too much on a new era then
you run the risk of making mistakes
that'll cost you even more time but I
find and I'm sure this is a consolation
to you that the first time I try
anything I rarely get it right I make
mistakes and come up against obstacles I
hadn't planned on the second time well
that's a different story the second time
is usually a lot faster it takes me
typically about onethird the time of the
previous Tri and that's true of
diagnosing and solving errors too so the
mindset to have here is not to blame
yourself but recognize this getting
stuck issue as a necessary and
unavoidable part part of coding and an
important part of your learning
experience also remember that the first
few times are the worst like anything
else the first few times are the worst
it's going to be slow and frustrating
needs a lot of patience and focus on not
rushing yourself things are going to
break things are going to make no sense
sometime you're going to get stuck in a
hole and you're not going to know how to
get out of it for a few hours that's
just how it is and it's okay sometimes
you've chased the wrong angle and you
need to rewrite an entire chunk of code
I've had to do that several times even
recently I thought I'd research the
library pretty well and used it in a
small project 5 days later I found out
that the library does not actually do
something the exact way I needed it to I
had designed my app the wrong way it was
my fault and I could either rewrite my
code to fit this library or start
researching again to find another
library or write my own code from
scratch instead of using that Library
all these options were going to take me
time and I found that out after being
stuck for a few days so i' already lost
time I had made the mistake of rushing
another 2 hours of reading on the
library would have given me the
information I needed to design my app
right from the start and saved me
potentially over 8 days so getting stuck
is normal it's part of the experience
don't rush yourself don't let despair
overcome your desire to be creative
through code this is one of the less fun
parts of being a developer there is no
doubt so just focus on the fun parts to
keep your motivation up and to conclude
let me show you something else from one
Kora user reading it definitely made me
feel better so don't worry about getting
stuck just keep moving forward and now
let's move forward to the next video
Welcome Back in the last video we talked
about getting stuck a lot and how that's
fairly normal but also there are very
good mindsets and techniques to deal
with that problem in this video we're
going to talk about another very common
source of setbacks for coders which is
making unfavorable
comparisons as humans we tend to compare
ourselves with others that's normal but
it's almost always
unfavorable and unhelpful because it has
a particularly negative effect when it
impacts your confidence as well I know
quite a few people who think that coding
is what they show in the movies or on TV
nope it's not not equally don't assume
that you can build the same sort of
application that Google can after all
they have thousands of developers
working on every small line of code when
you feel this way and find that you're
making these sort of demoralizing
comparisons speak to an experienced
Mentor or model or someone who's done
what you're trying to do they will give
you a perspective that is closer to
reality and look if you're going to
compare yourself then do it in these two
ways is one if they can do it I can two
two if they could do it in 1976 or in
1996 when the world didn't even have the
kind of resources we now have and there
was no Google and no stack Overflow then
it's much easier for me to do it now or
rather it was much harder for them and
I've got it easy compared to them so
even if you secretly think you're not as
smart as they are
fine I don't agree but fine you don't
need to be you can do what they can do
cuz you've actually got it easier just
remember that Bill Gates and Steve wnc
and Mark Zuckerberg and Jack dorsy are a
bunch of self-taught folks who taught
themselves in a world where resources
were significantly harder to access than
they are today so if they can do it with
those constraints you can absolutely do
it with all the material freely
available on on your fingertips today
the mindset to have here is that it's
never been easier to become a coder and
it's easier for me to do it than it was
for them okay let's move to the next
video okay welcome back everybody in
this video we now conclude the section
on the setbacks and the corresponding
mindsets that'll help you overcome those
setbacks this section is one of the most
important in the entire course because
this is the section that I think you
will keep coming back to over the months
and years that you try to teach yourself
to code because it's the one that's
going to help you overcome a lot of
those obstacles and you're going to
remember a lot of the things I say here
when you encounter those
obstacles it's not hard to learn to code
but it is a difficult task to persist in
learning to code so this section is so
important so fundamental to your success
in learning to code that I'm going to
spend this conclusion video just
wrapping up and recapping all the key
messages from each of the videos in the
section so that you also have it in the
one place let's keep
going so the key ideas in this section
are the
following one learning to code is very
confusing everything you read is going
to feel confusing at first the mindset
you need to have is it's okay it's
normal it's just a signal that maybe
you've skipped ahead too far and you
need to wind back just a little bit
reverse out of the situation back out
slowly and then break your next step up
into smaller pieces into smaller next
steps go for the quick wins so your
confidence stays up and you have a
strong sense of your own
progress idea two you're feeling
overwhelmed yep that's fairly common and
normal too and it's usually two types of
being overwhelmed one is from too much
information and the other is from
finding out that you may have
underestimated how much you need to
do both apply very commonly to learning
complex skills that's always a hard
thing to do but you know it's very
rewarding when you persist feeling
overwhelmed is a useful signal as well
it tells you that maybe you're biting
off more than you can chew mentally so
again break it down smaller pieces make
it easier to digest often we're just
trying to pile our priorities one on top
of the other instead stop step back
separate your priorities so that there
steps along a path and not one big
jumbled
pile test each step to make sure it's
100% necessary to achieve your
goals make sure that without taking that
step you cannot achieve your
goal number three you're feeling a lot
of self doubt this is totally normal and
Universal it's a human thing it just
proves you're human that's good right
remind yourself that it is not that you
cannot do something it's that you cannot
do something as yet this is the sign of
a growth mindset next remind yourself
that the only way to do it is by doing
it over and over again just keep going
it will click into place in time
guaranteed and if you need extra
inspiration remember Rocky it ain't
about how hard you hit it's about how
hard you can get hit and keep moving
forward number four progress is so slow
yes it is progress is always slow for
new skills progress demands that you
have patience and persistence for extra
help go back to your five ws and remind
yourself of your why why are you doing
this
the danger is not that you can't do it
it's that you will lose patience and
quit if your why is important enough you
won't quit it's that simple it's not
easy but it's simple and think of it as
math success is always equal to effort
plus time and since time is half the
equation the more time you spend the
more progress you're going to make for
super inspiration read that letter from
coach s to Tim Ferris included in the
book tools of
Titans number five getting stuck a lot
yep that's normal it's part of the
experience of programming at all levels
of experience you deal with it first by
reminding yourself that maybe this is
going to take a little more time than
you had planned that's okay got to
accept it then slowly start
investigating the problem and unravel it
piece by piece it is not possible to
learn to code without having to start
over on some things that is just a
normal part of coding so don't fight it
and it will be easier to deal with but
the first few times are always always
very hard and always takes you a lot
more time but every time you do it you
get faster and you get better number six
comparing yourself to others for example
I'm not like Zuck if you do compare
yourself then do it in a way that favors
you for example
if Zach can do it you absolutely can and
if Steve Jobs and wnc and Bill Gates
could do it without any of the resources
you have today conveniently at your
fingertips then recognize it was much
harder for them which means you can
absolutely do it okay I think you've got
some formidable tools and mindsets and
weapons Here In Your Arsenal to pursue
your dream to code let's wrap this up so
that we can get you started on your
journey as soon as possible I'll see you
in the next
video congratulations guys you've made
it to the end I am so incredibly excited
for you and proud of you and what we've
done together this is fantastic look
you've got your training shoes on you
are so ready you are so ready for the
marathon of learning to code and I would
argue you're actually ready to learn
pretty much any new skill that you want
this just happens to be about coding for
this course right I hope you enjoyed
yourself as much as I did um sharing
with you all the the stuff that I've
learned over the years and if you still
here till this very end point um that
means you've got the ability to persist
and you know what I say the only thing
that stands between you and your goal is
time and effort and lots of practice but
if you've made it this far then that
means you're willing to put in the work
which is fantastic hopefully through the
help of this course you've now got tools
and Frameworks that will help you reduce
the amount amount of time and effort
required to achieve your learning
objectives but there's no getting around
the fact that time and effort is what
it's going to take so I have no doubt
that you're going to get there and I'm
really excited that you've come to the
end couple of things just um sort of
housekeeping towards the end one if you
could keep contributing to the Q&A as
you go through your Learning Journey
that would be most valuable to all of us
selfishly I would love to hear how this
course has helped and how you've
personally experienced some of the
things I've talked about in this course
but also I think the rest of this
student Community would get a lot from
knowing that other students their peers
could be like models and mentors to them
in showing them their personal
application of some of the lessons from
this uh course so if you do have some
stuff like that to share please please
please share it on on the Q&A and also
reach out to me on Twitter and and share
it on Twitter because that's another
great way to show the world that you've
made such good progress that you've got
the initiative and the drive to do what
you're doing so definitely share it on
the Q&A and on Twitter finally I think
it's safe to say that now is a really
good time for you to pause and save the
moment like celebrate because you've
taken an enormous Leap Forward in your
demonstration of your willingness to do
what it takes do whatever it takes to
win and to achieve your learning
objective like I said no doubt that
you're going to make it you're going to
nail it keep going don't stop and if
there's anything you need I'm right here
all right good
luck